I'm Jenna Fisher and I'm Angela Kinsey. We were on The Office together and we're best friends. And now we're doing the ultimate Office Lovers podcast just for you. Each week we will dive deeper into the world of the office with exclusive interviews behind the scenes details and lots of BFF stories. We're the Office Lady 6.0. That's Chelsea Fry of... I'm just like still so happy from hearing that theme song
我是詹娜·费舍尔，我是安吉拉·金西。我们曾一起出演过《办公室》，并且是最好的朋友。现在我们专门为你带来终极的“办公室爱好者”播客。每周我们都会通过独家采访、幕后细节和许多闺蜜故事，带你更深入地了解办公室的世界。我们是办公室女郎 6.0。那是来自……的切尔西·弗莱。我听到那个主题曲还是觉得太开心了
and being here and watching you too because you're the cutest things ever. We're all just grinning at each other. Yeah, we're really happy right now. It's very happy. It's a real joyful room. I mean, we were saying this right when you got here, but we have just fallen in love with you so much. Your performance in the paper is fantastic, and we're just delighted, and you're just a nice human, too. So we're so happy you're here. I'm just so excited because I feel like watching you on the show and watching the show blow up as it has, it's really taking me back to those memories from the office. And I'm just like so excited for you that I have to imagine your acting dreams are coming true. Yes, beyond. Beyond.
而且能来到这里，看着你们两个，因为你们是最可爱的。我们都在冲着对方咧嘴笑。是的，我们现在真的很开心。非常开心。这是一个充满喜悦的房间。我是说，你刚来的时候我们就这么说过，但我们已经深深地爱上你了。你在《报纸》里的表演棒极了，我们太高兴了，而且你也是个很好的人。所以我们很高兴你能来。我真的很兴奋，因为我觉得看着你在剧里演出，看着这部剧像现在这样大火，真的把我带回了在《办公室》时的那些回忆。我真的为你感到高兴，我想象得出你的演员梦想正在成真。是的，远远超出想象。远远超出。
Yeah. What has it been like? Well, it's so funny because I remember when you guys came to set, I don't even, it must have been like early on in shooting and I was so nervous to meet you both because I think everybody on the show knows like I am the biggest OG office fan. Really? Yes. Like Beyond, I've seen every episode of 400 times. Like I'm one of those. And so not only getting on the show, then you guys coming and I just remember how sweet you were. And we were just like so in the thick of it and so nervous. And especially those early days, you're kind of just like, you're finding it. Yeah. And like waiting for the tap on the shoulder of like, you're not working. I feel like I felt like the first two months being like, is this real? Am I actually still here? And then you guys came
是啊。感觉怎么样？哦，太有趣了，因为我记得你们俩来片场的时候，我甚至不知道，那一定是在拍摄初期，我见你们俩时紧张得要命，因为我觉得剧组里每个人都知道，我是《办公室》最大的资深粉丝。真的吗？是的。就像是，我都把每一集看了400遍。我就是那种粉丝。所以不仅能参演这部剧，然后你们还过来了，我只记得你们当时人特别好。而我们当时正处在焦头烂额之中，紧张得不行。特别是那些刚开始的日子，你基本上就是在摸索。是的。就像是在等着有人拍拍你的肩膀说“你没被录用”。我觉得前两个月我总觉得，这是真的吗？我真的还在这里吗？然后你们来了
and it was just, it was so sweet. It was so sweet and meant so much to me. But yeah, it's been surreal. Like since minute one of meeting Greg and Michael and just doing the first audition, it's just been like, wait, what? I get to talk to these people and be a part of this world. It's crazy. I loved our first time meeting you. And on the set, we sat in like an abandoned cafeteria or something. Yeah, you did. It's what it felt like. And you were just so, gosh, like Jenna said, you were just so full of that I'm at the beginning. I'm at the beginning. And we talked about it for a long time, how special that was. And now we've watched the whole first season. And we sort of, my God, we didn't know who Mare was when we met you.
然后就，真的是太暖心了。太暖心了，对我意义重大。不过，是的，这感觉太超现实了。从见到格雷格和迈克尔的第一分钟起，从完成第一次试镜开始，就一直觉得，等等，什么？我能和这些人说话，还能成为这个世界的一部分。太疯狂了。我很喜欢我们第一次见你。在片场时，我们坐在一个废弃的自助餐厅还是什么地方。是的，确实是。感觉就是那样。你当时，天哪，就像詹娜说的，你浑身都散发着那种“我是新人”的状态。我是个新人。我们谈论了很久，觉得那特别特别。现在我们看完了整个第一季。我们有点，天啊，我们见到你时都不知道梅尔是谁。
And now we're obsessed with Mare. Thank you. And now you're doing season two, right? You're currently filming. We sure are. Wow. It's so fun. And I feel like I just want to gab about everything.
而现在我们对梅尔着迷了。谢谢你们。现在你们在拍第二季，对吧？你们目前正在拍摄。我们当然在拍。哇。太有趣了。我觉得我简直想把所有事情都拿出来闲聊一番。
But yeah, I feel it's so funny coming back now that we all know each other and getting to, you know, it's just you're so lucky. So many shows don't even get to go past one season. And just to get to come back and hear about each other's lives and we're all so much more comfortable. It's honestly, Donald and I were. saying the other day, we're just having so much fun. And just everyone is just making each other laugh and happy to be back together. That's the best. Yeah. It's so fun. And it's, I mean, I'm sure, because did you guys shoot? How many months a year would you guys shoot? Because you did like,
不过，是的，我觉得现在大家互相都认识了再回来拍戏，感觉太有趣了，而且能够，你知道的，你真的很幸运。很多剧甚至都拍不到第二季。能再次回来，听听彼此的生活，而且我们都自在多了。老实说，唐纳德和我说过，我们现在过得太开心了。每个人都逗彼此笑，都很高兴能重新聚在一起。这才是最棒的。是的。太有趣了。而且，我是说，我敢肯定，因为你们拍过吗？你们一年拍几个月？因为你们拍了，比如
what, 22? 22. 28 sometimes. Oh, my gosh. We would shoot usually from about late July all the way to April. So we would just have a very short amount of time off. Yeah. That's crazy. Yeah. And by the end of the season, we all got sick. Oh, but everyone gave in. Their bodies were like, I'm done. I feel like your body, like, knows as it's coming to an end. It's always those last couple weeks, you're like, I just got to stuff it down for a couple more weeks, and then I can just be in my bed for like two weeks after. And our writers, you know, it seemed like they never stopped working. They would get like two weeks off and then they would have to go back in for whatever
什么，22集？22集。有时甚至28集。哦，天哪。我们通常从大约7月下旬一直拍到4月。所以我们只有非常短的假期。是的。太疯狂了。是的。到了季末，我们全都生病了。哦，但大家都累垮了。身体都在抗议说：我受够了。我觉得身体似乎知道什么时候要结束了。总是最后那几周，你会想，我只要再咬牙坚持最后几周，然后就可以在床上躺上两个星期了。我们的编剧，你知道的，他们好像从不停止工作。他们大概只有两周的假期，然后就得回去投入到
two months of just like brainstorming the next season. So they were especially wiped by the end. Yeah. We're doing like January to end of April. So it's like half-ish a year almost, but it's amazing. But even I'm like we're talking, this week was our hiatus and it was so nice and we're all kind of just like, oh my gosh. But I can't imagine doing all year. But also I would do a million episodes. Well, something I'm very jealous of is that when you guys were getting to enjoy, like, the spoils of your season and your success and you're doing the press and you're getting to go to the fancy parties and all of that kind of stuff, you were not shooting.
长达两个月的下一季头脑风暴中。所以到最后他们尤其筋疲力尽。是的。我们是从1月拍到4月底。所以大约是一年的一半左右，这真的很棒。不过即使这样，我们谈到这周是我们的休假周，感觉太美妙了，我们大家都有点像，哦，天哪。不过我无法想象一整年都在拍。但同时我也愿意拍一百万集。好吧，我很嫉妒的一点是，当你们在享受你们的剧集和成功带来的成果，四处做宣传、去参加那些高档派对以及诸如此类的事情时，你们并没有在拍戏。
Yes. Yeah. I can't imagine. I don't know how you do that. Because it's like a job in and of itself to just promote the thing. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah.
是的。是的。我无法想象。我不知道你们是怎么做到的。因为光是宣传这件事本身就像是一份工作了。是的。是的。是的。
It was really fun. I got to go to New York with Oscar, and we had, like, two of the most fun nights. I've had in New York. It was like we were just let loose, so happy. And yeah, it was so fun. Oscar's really fun to travel with. I've had some accounting escapades. It's really fun.
真的很开心。我和奥斯卡一起去了纽约，我们度过了在纽约最开心的两个夜晚。感觉就像是我们被放飞了一样，太快乐了。是的，太有趣了。跟奥斯卡一起旅行真的很有趣。我有一些出彩的会计经历。真的很有趣。
It's true. Well, listen, we've been starting our episodes with a chit-chat suggestion from fans, and we thought maybe you'd like to participate in this one. I would love to participate. It's coming in from Chelsea Kay, and she is from Denver. Let's see what Chelsea, another Chelsea. I had to say. Hi office ladies, Chelsea from Denver here. Thank you so much for choosing my chit-chat question today.
确实如此。好了，听着，我们一直用粉丝提供的闲聊建议来开启每集节目，我们觉得你也许也想参与这一期。我很乐意参与。这是由来自丹佛的切尔西·K提出的。让我们看看切尔西，又一个切尔西。我得说。嗨，办公室女郎们，我是丹佛的切尔西。非常感谢你们今天选中我的闲聊问题。
My question for you is about the 26 Winter Olympics. If you could compete in any Olympic sport, pretending that you have all the skills in athleticism required, what would it be and why? Choose one sport for the Winter Olympics and one for the summer. Side note, how fun was it to see Sabrina from the paper with a huge starring role in the opening ceremonies. Thanks so much office ladies. Love you. So sweet. Oh, I love that question. Me too. I like this. The Olympics just ended. Yeah. I'm still sort of thinking about them. So this is kind of perfect. And Sabrina was in the opening ceremony. Oh my gosh. Amazing. Was it not out of this world? Yes. Yeah. I can't believe. And she was also doing that. We'd already
我给你们的问题是关于26年冬奥会的。如果你可以参加任何奥运会项目，假设你具备所需的所有技能和运动天赋，你会选哪个项目，为什么？请在冬奥会和夏奥会中各选一个项目。顺便说一句，看到《报纸》里的萨布丽娜在开幕式上有个巨大的领衔主演角色，有多酷啊。非常感谢办公室女郎们。爱你们。太甜了。哦，我喜欢这个问题。我也是。我喜欢这个。奥运会刚结束。是的。我还在琢磨它们。所以这简直太完美了。萨布丽娜居然在开幕式上。哦，天哪。太惊艳了。是不是宛如仙境？是的。是的。我真不敢相信。而且她当时还在进行，我们已经
started filming. And she was like in the middle of rehearsals. Learning the choreography. Yeah, but she didn't, she was like, oh, like I'm doing this, you know, piece at the beginning. Like, you'll see, you'll see. And I was like, I was like, I wonder what it could be. I had no idea. It was going to be like seven minutes straight. It was amazing.
开始拍戏了。她就像是在排练的间隙。学习编舞。是的，但她没说，她就说，哦，就像我在开头有这样一个，你知道的，片段。你会看到的，你会看到的。我就想，我就想知道会是什么。我完全不知道。竟然能连续跳七分钟。太惊人了。
I truly don't know how she did it with everything she has going on. It was like a long form, like modern dance. Yeah. Yeah. And storytelling. Yeah. Amazing. She told me, she wore, you know, like our hair had all those like tinsel and everything.
我真的不知道她是怎么在忙着其他所有事情的同时完成这一切的。那就像是一支长篇的现代舞。是的。是的。还有故事性。是的。太棒了。她告诉我，她戴着，你知道的，我们的头发里有那种亮片什么的。
She's like, I wore it back on the plane back to LA. She was like, I was. so tired. I just ended up, like, keeping it in my hair until I got back to LA. But yeah, it was so cool. We all watched it on set. Very exciting. All right. So should we answer Chelsea K's question? Yes. We got to. Who's going first? Chelsea? Yes, Chelsea. Okay. I mean, I feel like this is so basic, but figure skating? Yeah? Come on. I mean, it was really amazing this year. It was so cool. But yeah, I mean, if I could be in one of those cute little outfits. Oh my gosh. Would you be doubles or single? Singles.
她说：“我戴着它坐飞机回了洛杉矶。”她说：“我太累了。我干脆就让它留在头发里，直到回到洛杉矶。”不过，是的，太酷了。我们在片场一起看了。非常令人兴奋。好了，那我们应该回答切尔西·K的问题吗？是的。我们得回答。谁先来？切尔西？是的，切尔西。好吧。我的意思是，我觉得这太大众化了，不过是花样滑冰？是吗？拜托。我的意思是，今年真的太惊艳了。太酷了。不过，是的，如果我能穿上那些可爱的小衣服。哦，天哪。你是选双人还是单人？单人。
Singles. Single, yeah. You don't want anyone throwing you in the air. No, no, I know. But, yeah, I think I would be single. And I liked how she, like, played with, like, her hair and makeup. I feel like people were, like, starting to have a lot of fun. Right.
单人。单人，是的。你可不想让别人把你扔到半空中。不，不，我知道。不过，是的，我觉得我会选单人。我喜欢她那种，比如，摆弄她的头发和妆容的方式。我觉得大家好像，开始玩得很开心。对的。
And the music, so fun. Yeah. Yeah. She really embraced the whole disco moment. So cool. Such joy. That's the one thing. I feel like I would be so overcome with nerves.
音乐也超级有趣。是的。是的。她真的完美融入了迪斯科的氛围。太酷了。充满了欢乐。那是唯一的一点。我觉得我会紧张到不知所措。
I don't know that I'd be able to enjoy it. Would you guys? That's a good question. Wait, what's your winter sport? All right. I became a little obsessed with the biathlon. So this is the one where the person sort of like cross-country skis as fast as they can. Sure. And then they have to shoot a rifle at a target and you have to hit all the targets before you can keep skiing again. And it brought back those like sort of survivalist old-timey, snowy prairie vibes to me, which is just sort of one of my like obsessions. This is very you. This is the most on-brand answer. and all the years I've known you. Like if I could, as Chelsea K said, have all the skills and athleticism required. I would love to just like cross-country my way, do some target practice and move on.
我不知道自己能不能好好享受它。你们会吗？是个好问题。等等，你的冬奥项目是什么？好吧。我对冬季两项有点着迷。就是那种选手尽可能快地进行越野滑雪。没错。然后他们必须用步枪射击靶子，你必须在继续滑雪之前击中所有靶子。这让我回想起那种带点生存主义色彩的、老式的、雪地草原的感觉，这也是我的痴迷点之一。这很符合你的风格。这是我认识你这么多年来最符合你个人风格的答案。正如切尔西·K所说，如果我可以拥有所需的所有技能和运动天赋。我很乐意就这样一路越野滑雪，做些靶标练习，然后继续前进。
But I would love to add a third element. I would just want to propose this to the Olympic Committee. Maybe it's a triathlon because to make my dream come true, I need them to do a second stop where they just like chop a pile of wood. So it's like cross-country skiing and an axe shooting. Yes, and then they pull the axe out and they just like hack up a whole pile of wood. Do they have to like make a fire or just the wood? And somebody else makes the fire.
不过我更想加上第三个元素。我想向奥林匹克委员会提议这一点。也许是个铁人三项，因为为了让我的梦想成真，我需要他们增加第二项：劈一堆木柴。所以就像是越野滑雪加上射斧头。对，然后他们把斧子拔出来，接着去劈一堆木柴。他们还得生个火还是只要劈木柴？别人来生火。
That's a good idea. They have to quickly build a small like shelter. Sleep overnight and then back and we watch the entire thing. Yeah, I'm in. Yeah. So that would be mine. And I think I would love to be in the biathlon. All right.
这主意不错。他们必须迅速搭建一个小庇护所。睡一晚，然后回去，我们看整个过程。好吧，我加入。是的，所以这就是我的选择。我想我愿意参加冬季两项。好啦。
Okay. Well, I love watching the half pipe. I mean, I love all the Olympics. But if I had all the skills, there's something about just going down, I say it like I've done it. I haven't done it. There's just something about going down that half pipe and catching that air, watching them just fly and flip and twist and then come down and whoosh, they do it again. that would be the coolest thing.
好吧，我很喜欢看U型池。我的意思是，我喜欢所有的奥运会。但如果我拥有所有技能，那种冲下去的感觉——我说得好像我做过一样。我根本没做过。冲下U型池并腾空而起，看着他们飞跃、翻转、旋转，然后落下，呼的一声，再次冲上去。那绝对是最酷的事情。
I would love that. But yeah, and then I don't know if you guys saw this. This is the other thing I'd probably love because it's giant shuffleboard, but curling, I got still out. You see curling? Curling wouldn't stop. I'm like, we're still curling?
我会很喜欢那个。不过，是的，我不知道你们有没有看到这个。这是我可能会喜欢的另一个项目，因为它是巨型冰壶，但冰壶，我还是搞不懂。你们看冰壶了吗？冰壶停不下来。我就想，我们还在冰壶吗？
How many perjitations of curling are there? Curling went on longer than I thought it could. It's so true. It was true. It was like on every day, but like they've got one slidy shoe and one grippy shoe. And then there's one person who just yells,
冰壶有多少种变体啊？冰壶持续的时间比我想象的还要长。真的如此。确实如此。感觉每天都有，而且他们一只鞋底滑，一只鞋底有抓地力。然后有个人一直在大喊，
curl, curl, curl! I don't know, I'd be really into it. Did you see the brother-sister team? Were they brother-sister? Are they a couple? They truly looked like Dwight and Angela to me. Stop it. Or they looked like Dwight and Angela's children.
擦冰，擦冰，擦冰！我不知道，我对这个挺感兴趣的。你们看到那个兄妹组合了吗？他们是兄妹吗？他们是情侣吗？他们在我看来简直就是德怀特和安吉拉。得了吧。或者他们看起来像德怀特和安吉拉的孩子。
I mean, I'm going to need a visual at some point. That really took off. I think you posted that in your stories. I did. And then I think it inspired someone to then actually make like a meme of Angela and Dwight. Did you see that? No.
我的意思是，我迟早得看一眼画面。那个真的火了。我想你把它发在你的快拍里了。我发了。然后我觉得它启发了某人，制作了一个安吉拉和德怀特的表情包。你们看到了吗？没有。
Oh my God. And full Olympic like clothing. Stop it. And it, yeah, I have it. I'll show it to you guys. It's crazy. Yes, look. Lady, it's.
哦，天哪。穿着全套奥运服装。别这样。而且，是的，我有。我会给你们看。太疯狂了。对，看。天哪，太……
Isn't that hilarious? I'm dying. But I do think that I do think the Shrewts would play that game. Yeah. I do too. Yeah. They'd be pretty good. Guys, what's our summer sport?
是不是超级搞笑？我快笑死了。不过我确实觉得，我确实觉得施鲁特一家会玩那个游戏。是的。我也这么觉得。他们肯定玩得挺好。伙计们，我们的夏奥项目是什么？
I mean, I know mine immediately. What? What is that? mine immediately. Tennis? Yes. Are you a tennis girl? I am. I love tennis. It's my favorite thing. Let's get you out there. I know, right? Like ladies, 50s, 3.5 U.S.T.A. Ranking. Yeah. Yeah. I'm sure a lot of people would want to watch the slow, slow, slow, slow sport I would do in tennis. I mean, sometimes our coach, like, films us, and I just think I'm running so hard. Yeah, yeah. And then he plays it back, and I'm like, oh, my God.
我的意思是，我立刻就知道我的选什么。什么？是什么？我立刻就知道。网球？是的。你是网球女孩吗？我是。我超爱网球。这是我最喜欢的事。带你上场打几拍。对吧？就像女士们，50岁，3.5美网分级。是的。是的。我敢肯定很多人会想看我在网球场上那种慢、慢、慢、慢的运动。我是说，有时我们的教练会给我们录像，我只觉得自己跑得好拼命。对，对。然后他回放给我看，我就想，天哪。
This is the slowest, lamest moving group of women. What's your summer sport? I mean, I love the divers. Oh, yeah. They're so scary. So scary. But I'm always like when they make the little splash, I want to be able to make that little splash.
这是史上动作最慢、最逊的一群女人的运动。你的夏奥项目是什么？我是说，我喜欢跳水。哦，对。太吓人了。太吓人了。但每次他们激起小小的水花时，我都希望自己能激起那样的小水花。
When I dive in a pool, it's like, but I would love to be able to do that. I think that would be mine. Again, if I had all the skills in the world. Yeah. I would want to swim the butterfly. The butterfly. Yeah. With your broken shoulder.
当我跳进泳池时，就像是“扑通”，但我好希望能做到那样。我想那会是我的选择。同样，如果我拥有世上所有的技能。是的。我想游蝶泳。蝶泳。是的。带着你骨折的肩膀。
Well, I have all the skills in the world, lady. And all the athletes are required. My best friend in high school growing up, she was a competitive butterfly swimmer. And she just looks so cool. Yeah. And it's a really hard stroke. And I just feel like it would be like mad respect. And I've never in my life even done a single butterfly stroke.
好吧，我拥有世上所有的技能，女士。以及所有需要的运动天赋。我上高中时最好的朋友，她是一名竞技蝶泳运动员。她看起来太酷了。是的。而且那是一个很难的泳姿。我只是觉得这会赢得疯狂的尊重。而且我这辈子连一个蝶泳划水动作都没做过。
Like I can't just, I never figured it out. So like if I could just wish to suddenly be able to do something and do it. well and fast and like maybe you win gold. I don't know. Maybe silver, but we just have to see who who else is up in butterfly that year. That's the thing. It's not just you. It's like who else, you know? But in this hypothetical world, we all meddle, guys. We all melmelt. Well, that is the thing. We're going to meddle. Maybe it's not the gold, but we're on the podium. For sure. Definitely. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. For America. Of course. For America. Yeah. Well, that was really fun. Yeah. Thank you, Chelsea Kay.
就像我根本，我从来没学会过。所以，如果我能许愿突然就能做到某件事并且做得很好、很快，也许还能赢得金牌。我不知道。也许是银牌，但我们得看看当年蝶泳还有谁入围了。关键就在这里。不仅是你一个人。还要看其他人，你知道的？但在这种假设的世界里，我们都会拿奖牌的，伙计们。我们都会拿奖牌的。好吧，那就是重点。我们要拿奖牌。也许不是金牌，但我们能站上领奖台。肯定的。绝对的。是的。是的。为了美国。当然。为了美国。是的。那真的太有趣了。是的。谢谢你，切尔西·K。
Why don't we take a break and then we're going to come back and we are going to break down the Ohio Journalism Awards, the season finale of season one of the paper with Chelsea Frye. This show is sponsored by BetterHelp. You know, we are going to take a moment to celebrate women and all that they carry at work, in relationships and families and in the many roles they hold every single day. And we need to remind ourselves about how much we matter. and that therapy offers a space for us to take care of ourselves in the way we deserve. Therapy can also be a place to set boundaries and build confidence. Just take care of your own well-being for a change. BetterHelp makes therapy accessible and flexible.
我们为什么不休息一下，然后回来和切尔西·弗莱一起剖析俄亥俄州新闻奖，也就是《报纸》第一季的季终集。本节目由 BetterHelp 赞助。你知道，我们要花点时间来赞美女性以及她们在工作、人情世故、家庭以及她们每天扮演的众多角色中所承担的一切。我们需要提醒自己，我们有多么重要，并认识到心理治疗为我们提供了一个空间，让我们能够以应有的方式照顾自己。心理治疗也可以是一个设定界限、建立自信的地方。为了改变现状，好好照顾你自己的身心健康吧。BetterHelp 让心理治疗变得触手可及且灵活。
Their therapists are fully licensed in the U.S. and follow a strict code of conduct. With over 30,000 therapists, BetterHelp is the world's largest online therapy platform, and it works, with an average rating of 4.9 out of 5 for a lot of, session based on over 1.7 million client reviews. Your emotional well-being matters. Find support and feel lighter in therapy. Sign up and get 10% off at betterhelp.com slash office ladies. That's better H-E-L-P dot com slash office ladies. I'm Craig Melvin. Cheers. Cheers. I've always been a glass half-hole kind of guy. And now I'm talking to some people who look at the world that way too. Some really fascinating folks who share their defining moments, their triumphs, their challenges. Their stories are funny
他们的治疗师在美国都拥有完全执照，并遵守严格的行为准则。BetterHelp 拥有超过 3 万名治疗师，是全球最大的在线心理治疗平台，而且它确实有效，根据超过 170 万客户的评价，基于会话的平均评分高达 4.9 分（满分 5 分）。你的情绪健康很重要。在心理治疗中寻找支持，卸下重担。注册并在 betterhelp.com/officeladies 上享受 9 折优惠。网址是 better H-E-L-P点com斜杠 office ladies。我是克雷格·梅尔文。干杯。干杯。我一直是个乐观主义者。现在我正在和一些同样这样看待世界的人交谈。一些非常迷人的人，他们分享自己的高光时刻、他们的胜利、他们的挑战。他们的故事妙趣横生
and quite candid. So I hope you'll join me each week. And who knows, you might just come away with your own glass apple. Search Glass Half Full with Craig Nelson from today on YouTube and wherever you get your podcasts. All right, we are back with Chelsea to break down the Ohio Journalism Awards. And before we get to it, ladies, I have a little something for you from Toledo. What? From Toledo. from Toledo, Ohio. What? I ordered it a bit ago.
又十分坦诚。所以我希望你每周都能加入我的节目。谁知道呢，说不定你也能带着自己的乐观态度离开呢。在 YouTube 以及你获取播客的任何地方搜索来自 Today 的 Craig Melvin 主持的《Glass Half Full》。好的，我们带着切尔西回来了，接下来要剖析俄亥俄州新闻奖。在开始之前，女士们，我从托莱多给你们带了一点小礼物。什么？来自托莱多。来自俄亥俄州托莱多。什么？我前阵子订的。
I'm so excited to give it to you. As you know, there's a runner in the whole series about the Toledo Mudhens. Oh, yes. And I felt like we all needed some Toledo Mudhands merch. No. This is crazy. No. Wait, it's so cute.
我太高兴把它送给你们了。如你们所知，整部剧中有一个关于托莱多泥母鸡队的支线。哦，是的。我觉得我们大家都需要一些托莱多泥母鸡队的周边。不会吧。太疯狂了。不会吧。等等，太可爱了。
It's so cute. It's like a Navy t-shirt. It says Toledo Mudhens baseball. And it looks, it's like a little white. razor back. Stop it. Okay. You were so cute.
太可爱了。这是一件海军蓝T恤。上面写着托莱多泥母鸡棒球队。看起来，就像是一个小白。拉面。别这样。好吧。你太可爱了。
I don't have any Toledo merch yet. This is amazing. Seriously? I can't wait. You can't wait. You can't have. They also gave me an obvious lady's mug and an obvious lady's tote. I'm going to be merged out.
我还没有任何托莱多的周边呢。这太棒了。真的吗？我等不及了。你等不及了。你等不了了。他们还给了我一个办公室女郎的马克杯和一个办公室女郎的托特包。我的周边要多得放不下了。
This is so sweet. Thank you. All right. Well, that definitely put me in a Toledo movie. Me too. I know. All right. Well, let's get to it.
太贴心了。谢谢你们。好吧，这绝对让我进入了托莱多的状态。我也是。我知道。好了，那我们开始吧。
All right. Well, this episode was written by Paul Lieberstein and directed by Jeffrey Blitz. Jenna, how about a summary? Here it is. Relationships are made and broken when the Toledo Truth Teller team attends the Ohio Journalism Awards. Asmeralda and Ken fight to appear relevant, Nicole catches Detrick in a lie, and Oscar comes to terms with life as a documentary subject. Meanwhile, Marinette do some investigative journalism that turns, shall we say, personal. Yeah. Yeah. There's a lot to discuss there. We'll get there. This episode opens on like a big awards night.
好的，这一集由保罗·利伯斯坦编剧，杰弗里·布里茨执导。詹娜，来个总结怎么样？来啦。当“托莱多实话实说”团队参加俄亥俄州新闻奖时，人际关系或建立或破裂。阿斯梅尔达和肯极力争取刷存在感，妮可抓住了迪特里希的一个谎言，奥斯卡则开始接受自己作为纪录片拍摄对象的命运。与此同时，玛丽和内特进行了一些调查性报道，结果变得，怎么说呢，相当私人化。是的。是的。有很多事情要讨论。我们这就讲到。这一集开场是一个盛大的颁奖之夜。
We're at a hotel. All the tables are there. The banquet tables, the flowers. It's going to be a fancy evening. Oscar has a talking head where he explains that the Truth Teller has been nominated for three awards. Mare is nominated for Her Softie's Clog Story. Ned is nominated for the paper itself.
我们在一个酒店里。所有的桌子都在那儿。宴会桌，鲜花。这将是一个华丽的夜晚。奥斯卡有一个单人采访镜头，他在其中解释说“实话实说”获得了三项提名。玛丽因《她的软袜堵塞的故事》获得提名。内特因报纸本身获得提名。
and Oscar is nominated for his little puzzle that he does, Mr. Digit. It's so perfect. That storyline is perfection for him. He also says it's been a very long time since the Truth Teller won one of these awards, and we're going to flash back to the last time this happened. It's 1971. So long ago, you guys, so long ago, it's the year I was born. Yes, we only have black and white footage of that.
奥斯卡则因他制作的小拼图《数字先生》获得提名。太完美了。那个剧情线对他来说简直完美。他还说“实话实说”赢得这类奖项是很久以前的事了，我们要闪回到上一次发生这种事的时候。那是1971年。太久以前了，伙计们，太久以前了，那是俺出生的那一年。是的，我们只有那个时期的黑白录像。
moment because it's old, ye old, so old in time. Oh, Beijing 71. Yes. I'm surprised they had sound. I know. I know. Son of a bitch. I do have a background catch, Chelsea.
因为太古老了，古老的，年代太久远了。哦，北京71年。是的。我很惊讶他们当时有声音。我知道。我知道。狗娘养的。我确实有一个背景发现，切尔西。
I love a background catch. I noticed on the wall where the word show's happening. Yeah. That there's these like keypads and they say Glendale on them. Do you think. Yep. Wait. What do you mean?
我很喜欢背景发现。我注意到颁奖晚会现场的墙上。是的。有一些这样的键盘，上面写着格伦代尔。你觉得。没错。等等。什么意思？
Keypad? There's like a little, like, you know, like a keypad that would probably like, I don't know, turn on the lights or something. Sure, and it says Glendale. So we know, because did you film in Glendale? We sure did. Where did you film these? We shot at a hotel up there in Glendale.
键盘？有一个小小的，你知道的，就像那种大概会，我不知道，用来开灯什么的键盘。当然，上面写着格伦代尔。所以我们知道，因为你们是在格伦代尔拍摄的吗？我们当然是。你们在哪里拍的这些？我们在格伦代尔的一家酒店拍的。
And it sure was. And I'm sure like Finaleys felt like this for you guys too or episodes like the boat cruise or something where you're all just together in one place for like a few days and it's not at the lot. just feels kind of extra special. Sure, it's like a road trip. It's like a road trip. And they would like keep the bar open for us.
确实如此。我敢肯定《办公室》对你们来说也是这种感觉，或者像游船那一类的剧集，你们所有人都在一个地方待上好几天，而不是在片场。感觉特别特别。当然，这就像是一次公路旅行。就像是一次公路旅行。他们甚至会为我们开着酒吧。
So if we would like get out late, they'd like have a couple of drinks for us at the end of a night. It was so fun. I had so much fun that week. Did they move your trailers there? Or did you get a hotel room as a trailer? They brought everything there. But we ended up having a lot of meetings in those rooms.
所以如果我们很晚才收工，他们会在深夜给我们准备几杯饮料。太好玩了。那一周我过得太开心了。他们把你们的房车也搬到那里去了吗？还是说你们用酒店房间当房车？他们把所有东西都搬到那儿了。不过最后我们在那些房间里开了好多会。
They would like rent out like a couple floors of it. And so we would be up there gab and. Right. So you stayed at a hotel. Also used them for production. But then you had your whole. trailer set up and base camp for hair and makeup. Got it.
他们租下了其中的好几层楼。所以我们会在上面聊天。所以你们住在酒店里。酒店也用于制作。但你们有自己的房车设置和用于发型化妆的大本营。明白了。
Yeah, yeah, yeah. Well, I was very tickled by that background catch because when we filmed the office and we'd have driving scenes, fans would write in and be like, doesn't look like Scranton. So a palm tree. And now I feel like I'm that person like, I'm going Dale keypad. No, thanks so much. You've ruined the magic of the show. Not true.
是的，是的，是的。嗯，我对那个背景发现感到非常有趣，因为当我们拍摄《办公室》时，如果有开车戏，粉丝会写信来说：“看起来不像斯克兰顿。”比如一棵棕榈树。现在我觉得我成了那种人，我会说：“看，格伦代尔的键盘。”不，谢谢。你毁了这部剧的魔术。才没有。
No, it's true. I feel like we're always trying to get a palm tree out of the back of a shot. Right. Yeah. wish we could shoot in Real Toledo. Maybe one day we'll get to go there. Well, don't count on it. We never went to Scranton.
不，真的。我觉得我们总是在试图把镜头背景里的棕榈树去掉。对的。是的。希望我们能在真正的托莱多拍摄。也许有一天我们能去那儿。嗯，别指望了。我们从来没去过斯克兰顿。
You guys never went, right? But they went and shot some B-roll, I think. I think they did. I think John shot like B-roll for the titles, and maybe they went once. Now I feel like we're like the two old jaded aunties. We're like, don't count. You're never going to. Don't hold your breath.
你们从来没去过，对吧？但他们好像去拍了一些B滚素材。我想他们去过。我想约翰拍了一些用于片头的B滚素材，也许他们去过一次。现在我觉得我们就像两个饱经沧桑的老阿姨。我们就像是在说：“别指望了。你们永远也去不了。”别抱太大希望。
Nine years, we didn't go to Scrim. You're stuck in Glendale. That's as far as you'll go. So now Ned is going to greet Marv and Anne's husband, his brother, Lou. And then Esmeralda makes her entrance. Oh, yeah. And I think we need to discuss her gorgeous red gown. We did get a fan question from Regina C. and Barcelona, who said,
九年了，我们都没去过斯克兰顿。你们被困在格伦代尔了。那就是你们能去的极限了。现在，内特去迎接玛丽和安的丈夫、他的兄弟路。然后阿斯梅尔达登场了。哦，是的。我想我们得讨论一下她那条华丽的红裙子。我们确实收到了来自巴塞罗那的雷吉纳·C的粉丝提问，她说：
Hi, ladies, when I saw this episode and Esmeralda appeared on screen with that stunning red dress, I knew I had to find out more about it. It's perfection, the color, the drama with the flowers and the puffy sleeves, the head. Headpiece. Did they make it? Did they buy it? What are the details? So, Chelsea, I've been very obsessed with your wardrobe. Oh, thank you so much. This is true. And I have been going on these sites. One is called shopyotivy.com. Oh, yeah. I'll sometimes go on that because I love mare sweaters. And I'll forget where they're from from the first season. So I'll go to like buy them and try and find them on sale like a year later. Oh, yeah. So one of yours was on Farfetch. Oh, stop it.
嗨，女士们，当我看到这一集，看到阿斯梅尔达穿着那条惊艳的红裙子出现在屏幕上时，我知道我必须去了解更多关于它的信息。这简直完美，颜色、带有花朵和泡泡袖的戏剧感、头饰。头饰。是他们做的吗？是买的吗？有什么细节吗？所以，切尔西，我对你的戏服一直非常着迷。哦，非常感谢。这是真的。我一直在逛这些网站。其中一个叫 shopyotivy.com。哦，是的。我有时会上去看，因为我喜欢玛尔的毛衣。我会忘了第一季时它们是从哪儿买的。所以我常常会去买，试图在大约一年后找到它们打折款。哦，是的。所以你的其中一件在 Farfetch 上。哦，别这样。
That big block sweater, the black collar sweater with the collar. Yeah. Yeah. I have the details for you. Honestly, send it to me later. Well, this dress is by Salas London, Talia. It's off the shoulder. And it is also by Farfetch.
那件大方块毛衣，带领子的黑色毛衣。是的。是的。我有详细信息。说实话，回头发给我。好吧，这条裙子是 Salas London 的 Talia 款。是露肩的。而且也是在 Farfetch 上买的。
So I think Kathleen likes Farfetch, your costume designer. She sure does. So according, though, to the website, when you purchase this dress, it does not have the big flowers. So I traded emails with Kathleen Felix Hager, amazing costume designer, as we have said. Yeah. She sent over pictures, you guys, of the fitting. she did with Sabrina, and the costume department did, in fact, add all of the big flowers. Yeah, she's incredible.
所以我觉得凯瑟琳喜欢 Farfetch，你们的服装设计师。她确实喜欢。不过根据网站上的说法，当你购买这条裙子时，它并没有那些大花朵。所以我跟服装设计师凯瑟琳·菲利克斯·黑格（Kathleen Felix Hager）——正如我们所说，她是一位了不起的服装设计师——通过邮件交流过。是的。她发来了照片，各位，是她和萨布丽娜试装时的照片，服装部门确实加上了所有的那些大花朵。是的，她太不可思议了。
She's amazing. I adore her, and she's a genius. She does so many other shows, and we're so lucky to have her. But I remember in the script what made me laugh so hard during the table read, it described the dress as Marilda walks in as Met Gala. Like, basically, she thinks she's at the Met Gala, but it's the Ohio Journalism Awards. And I was like, that is Esmeralda. And like, of course, of course. If she's a night and, like, of course she's going to wear a tiara.
她太棒了。我爱死她了，她是个天才。她还参与了好多其他剧集的制作，我们能有她真的很幸运。不过我还记得在剧本里，台词围读时最让我捧腹大笑的是，当阿梅尔达走进来时，剧本把这套裙子描述为“Met Gala”风格。基本上，她觉得自己是在参加 Met Gala，但其实是俄亥俄州新闻奖。当时我就想，这太符合阿斯梅尔达的风格了。而且，当然，当然了。如果她出席晚会，她就一定会戴一顶王冠。
Like, there's no way she's not wearing a tiara. She has to. Right. But yeah, I remember when she walked in that first day, we were dying laughing. It was like more ridiculous than you could ever even imagine. And she just, like, looked amazing in it, which was like, it was just so fun. But yeah, that dress was amazing. Well, next up, it looks like Ned is holding a rabbit's foot.
她不可能不戴王冠。她必须戴。对的。不过，是的，我记得她第一天走进来时，我们都快笑死了。比你想象的还要荒谬。而且她穿起来居然看起来惊艳无比，这真的，太有趣了。不过，是的，那条裙子太棒了。接下来，看起来内特手里拿着一只兔脚。
People comment on it. He says it's not a rabbit's foot because he doesn't want to win. You know, I don't need to win. He's just happy to be there. He actually says it's part of a dead mouse that he found in the street. I feel like this is classic Ned because sometimes the thing that's the truth, he's like, I'll make up something way worse than what is the actual truth. Yes, that is such a great way to put Ned.
大家对此议论纷纷。他说这不是兔脚，因为他不想赢。你知道，我不需要赢。他只是很高兴能参与其中。他实际上说这是他在街上发现的一只死老鼠的一部分。我觉得这很典型，因为有时面对事实，他会说：“我会编出一个比真正的事实还要糟糕得多的故事。”是的，形容内特真是太贴切了。
And honestly, it's like reminding me of what we've been shooting. So I'm like, yes, that is an absolute fundamental character trait of his. And it's like so sweet and charming and also just like, oh my God. How could he possibly think that sounds better than what he's actually doing? But yeah, that rabbit's foot made me laugh so hard. Do you have any good luck charms? Are you a good luck charm person? Or good luck rituals or anything like that?
老实说，这让我想起了我们一直在拍摄的内容。所以我想，是的，这绝对是他一个根本的性格特质。既可爱迷人，又让人觉得，天哪。他怎么会觉得这听起来比他实际在做的事还要好呢？不过，是的，那个兔脚把我笑惨了。你们有什么幸运符吗？你们是相信幸运符的人吗？或者有什么好运仪式之类的东西吗？
That's such a good question. I'm trying to think I used to have a turtleneck I wore to like every audition that I've actually lost. I'm trying to remember, I guess I didn't wear it to my paper audition. But I used to, like, I had like one thing that I was always like, okay, if I wear this, I'm, you know, I think I'll do a good job. And I, like, booked a couple worlds. And it was, like, a really shi, like, old turtleneck.
这真是个好问题。让我想想，我以前有一件高领毛衣，我每次试镜都穿，不过后来弄丢了。我努力回想，我想我试镜《报纸》时好像没穿它。但我曾经，比如，我有一件固定行头的衣服，我总是会想，好吧，如果我穿这个，我，你知道的，我觉得我会表现得不错。而且我，比如，凭借它拿下了好几个角色。而且那是一件，非常破的，旧高领毛衣。
I wouldn't wear to everything. I'm picturing you, like, okay, this movie takes place on a cruise in the Caribbean. I'm like, well, I have to wear my turtle hat, or else I won't get it. I have to wear my tentative turtleneck sweater. I think that I'm not kidding. I think once or twice my age is really, could you resubmit that in like or something else? Because it's so wrong for the part. But it was my good luck charm.
我不是什么都穿它。我脑海里浮现出你的样子，比如，好吧，这部电影背景设定在加勒比海的一艘游轮上。我就想，好吧，我必须穿我的高领毛衣，否则我就拿不到角色了。我必须穿我的网球高领毛衣。我觉得我没开玩笑。我觉得有一两次我的年龄真的很，你能以某种方式重新提交吗？因为这跟这个角色太不搭了。但这是我的幸运符。
besides that, not really. I mean, I have my, like, silly little, like, routines in the morning that sometimes I'm, like, if I don't do this, but nothing, nothing like a good luck charm. Do you guys? I had a red blouse. Like, now that you mentioned this thing about auditioning and the same thing, I have this red blouse that if I wore it, I seem to get the part. And so I wore it to every audition. Did you wear it to audition for Pam? No, because it wasn't appropriate for Pam.
除此之外，真的没有了。我是说，我早上有一些，比如，傻里傻气的微小日常习惯，有时我会想，如果我不做这个，但真的没有什么像幸运符那样的东西。你们呢？我有一件红衬衫。既然你们提到了试镜和类似的事情，我确实有这么一件红衬衫，如果我穿它，我似乎总能拿到角色。所以我每次试镜都穿它。你试镜潘的时候穿了吗？没有，因为那不适合潘。
Okay. This was like when I had to play like a pediatric nurse, but sexy. Or like a school teacher, but hot. That's what this blouse was. Yes, of course. That's so funny. I don't really have a good, like, charm, but I do have one thing I do every time I fly. What?
好吧。这大概是我得演一个儿科护士，但又带点性感的时候。或者像个女教师，但很辣。这就是那件衬衫的风格。是的，当然。太搞笑了。我其实没有什么好运护身符，但我确实有一个每次坐飞机都会做的习惯。什么？
And now my kids do it. Is that bad? No, it's good. Okay, as I walk up to the plane, like, and I'm about to step through the threshold to get on it, I pat the plane. Like, come on, girl, you got this. And I watched a steward clock me doing it. Like, it's my turn to step, and I'm like, wait a second. Pat, pat, pat, pat.
现在我的孩子也这么做了。这很糟糕吗？不，这很好。好吧，当我走到飞机旁，就像正要跨过舱门登机时，我会拍拍机身。就像，加油，女孩，你行的。我看到一个乘务员盯着我做这个动作。就像，轮到我进去了，而我在想，等一下。拍，拍，拍，拍。
So it's so sweet. Yeah, that's what I do. The planes are tired. They just came from somewhere else. Sometimes they need a little... I just got this. You got this? I'm like, she tie-tie.
所以太可爱了。是的，这就是我做的。飞机也很累。它们刚从别的地方飞来。有时它们需要一点……我刚才明白了。你行的？我就想，她好累啊。
Those old ones? I'm like, what are we... What's happening here? Yeah. You get an extra pat. Okay, now we're in the opening credits. There's this runner, Jenna and I loved. It's Adam and his wife, and they're living it up at the awards.
那些老飞机？我就想，我们在干嘛……这到底怎么回事？是的。你得额外拍几下。好了，现在我们进入片头字幕。有一个支线，詹娜和我都很喜欢。亚当和他的妻子，他们在颁奖典礼上玩得很嗨。
They're drinking. It cuts to her, and she's at this long sort of dessert table, and she's just, like, got her plate piled. She's, like, stuffing a brownie into her mouth, and she's adorable. And it just made me think, Jenna, so much of, like, when we would go to award shows and we would hoard food. Well, because there isn't a lot of food.
他们在喝酒。镜头切到她身上，她站在一张长长的甜点桌旁，盘子里堆满了食物。她，就像是把一个布朗尼蛋糕塞进嘴里，而且她超级可爱。这让我忍不住想到，詹娜，我们以前去颁奖典礼时囤积食物的情形。因为那里并没有多少吃的。
This is what I hear. You know when it's like the little thin, like, cracker, but it's super skinny? What do you call that one? It looks like a straw, but it's a cracker. I don't even know. Like a breadstick. But it looks like two chopsticks. Sure, sure, sure, sure.
我是这么听说的。你知道那种细细的、像饼干一样，但超级细长的东西吗？那个叫什么来着？看起来像一根吸管，但它是个饼干。我甚至不知道。就像一根面包棒。但它看起来像两根筷子。当然，当然，当然，当然。
Two bread chopsticks. That's your bread. And then a giant jet of wine. A giant thing of wine. But then also, I feel like there would always be this sort of like congealed like a shrimp patte or something. Like something that feels like it had been on the taste. a while, so you're definitely not touching that. With like one lightly sliced carrot.
两根面包筷。这就是你的面包。然后是一大杯葡萄酒。一大杯酒。但除此之外，我觉得总会有那种凝固的、像虾酱一样的东西。感觉就像是在盘子里放了很久的东西，所以你绝对不会去碰它。配上一根切得薄薄的胡萝卜。
Sure. Sure. Of course. Your salad. But then all the wine you could ever want. Fun. Fun. But we have hoarded, like, bread before.
当然。当然。你的沙拉。但随之而来的是你想喝多少就有多少的葡萄酒。好玩。好玩。不过我们以前确实囤过面包。
Would you guys, like, go out after and eat, or was it before while you had to? Yeah, yeah. You had to. Or, you know, the after parties would have food, but, like, do you make it over there? Because it's like, you know, I feel like you're a bride at a, a wedding. You're talking to everybody and you never get a water or any food at all. Yeah. Totally. This is kind of a tangent. Huge tangent. I'm sure you guys have talked about this on the pod. So sorry. When did you guys become like best friends? Your face is so cute. She's doing that face like,
你们会，比如，结束后出去吃，还是在必须待在那里的期间吃？对的，对的。你必须去。或者，你知道的，会后派对上会有吃的，但是，比如，你能赶过去吗？因为感觉就像，你知道的，你就像婚礼上的新娘。你一直在跟每个人说话，根本喝不到水，也吃不到任何东西。完全是这样。这有点扯远了。扯得太远了。我敢肯定你们一定在播客里聊过这个。很抱歉。你们是什么时候成为好朋友的？你的表情太可爱了。她做那个表情就像是，
I'm going to cry before you win. No story. I mean, we always, we always say it was basketball. Yeah. I think the basketball episode, because we were mostly background in that. And so they just sat us on a bench for three days, 12 hours a day, and we just told each other our life stories. Okay, that was it. That's all I wanted to know. Sorry. So it was kind of there. Yeah.
在你赢之前我都要哭了。没故事。我是说，我们总是，我们总说是打篮球那次。是的。我觉得是因为篮球那一集，因为我们在那里面大多演背景群众。所以他们只是让我们在长凳上坐了三天，一天12小时，我们就开始互相倾诉各自的人生故事。好吧，就是这样。我只想知道这个。抱歉。所以差不多就是从那开始的。是的。
And then it was like nice that we just shared a little partition, you know, like we were close to each other in the bullpen. So I would just hop up and I'd pop my head over and she'd do the same and we'd chat there. I think it's why the writers actually eventually wrote a scene with our two characters at the partition talking. Yeah. They would see us doing it. Yeah.
然后挺好的是，我们正好共用一个小隔板，你知道的，我们在办公区离得很近。所以我会时不时地蹦起来，把头探过去，她也一样，我们在那儿聊天。我想这就是为什么编剧后来专门写了一场我们两个角色在隔板处对话的戏。是的。他们会看到我们这么做。是的。
When Dwight froze sprinkles. I remember. But then we started going through similar things in life, you know? Like when the show started, we didn't have kids and then we had kids on the show. And then, you know, so it was like there were a lot of parts of our lives where like you needed a friend who understood. And similarly, like just all the fame and stuff, you know, like I didn't have any famous friends. So I didn't know who to ask about any of this stuff. Yeah.
当德怀特把Sprinkles冷冻的时候。我记得。但后来我们开始经历生活中相似的事情，你知道的？比如剧集刚开始时我们都没有孩子，后来我们在剧里有了孩子。然后，你知道的，所以生活中有很多部分，你会需要一个能懂你的朋友。同样地，就像所有的名气之类的，你知道的，我没有其他成名的朋友。所以我不知道该向谁打听这些事。是的。
And we just figured it out together and it was really helpful. It was helpful to admit that we didn't know things. Yeah. Yeah. You know, and then also like, what did you find out? What did you? Yeah. What did it?
我们是一起摸索过来的，真的很有帮助。承认我们不知道某些事情很有帮助。是的。是的。你知道的，还有，你发现了什么？你？是的。发现了什么？
And then our families, too, both of our families, like, no one in our families is in show business. Yeah, same, same. Right? So I was just like, where do you get the clothes? Yes. Where do the, literally where do you get the clothes? Yes.
然后我们的家庭也是，我们的两个家庭，我们在演艺圈都没有什么亲戚。是的，一样，一样。对吧？所以我就想，你从哪儿买的衣服？对啊。字面意义上，你到底从哪儿买的衣服？对的。
We spent a lot of time on that. Yeah. We couldn't figure out. Yeah. We never got great at it, by the way. Well, you hear stories, right? You're like, well, this person got something sent to them. How?
我们在这上面花了好多时间。是啊。我们弄不明白。是啊。顺便说一句，我们从来没有真正精通过。你听过一些故事，对吧？你会觉得，这人收到了别人寄来的东西。怎么收到的？
Literally how. How did it get sent? Like, who put that word out to send it? How did they know where to send it? Well, and it's like, I think you, it all looks so glamorous, you know, on Instagram, but it's like nobody sees like you lugging your like five garment bags by yourself through an airport being like, did I grab everything? What did I forget?
字面意义上的怎么收到的。到底是怎么寄到的？呃，是谁放出话来说要寄的？他们是怎么知道该寄到哪里的？而且就像是，我觉得你，在Instagram上看起来一切都那么光鲜亮丽，但没人看到的是你一个人拖着五大包服装袋走过机场，心里还在想：我是不是都拿齐了？我落下了什么？
I feel like I messed all this up. It's so, it's, I wouldn't say like, there are. many more things that are stressful in life, but it is such a, yeah, there's no like rulebook to do it. And so you're kind of just asking people, you know, and being exactly what you said, like, how do you do this? How did you do this? And trying not to look like an idiot. Well, I remember I had to relocate to London for a job for six months. And I had two little kids. My daughter was only seven months old. My son was three. So I flew ahead because I had to do extra fittings and things like that. And I had to find us an apartment and I had to get it furnished.
我觉得我把这一切都搞砸了。这太，这，我倒不会说生活中有更多让人焦虑的事情，但这确实是一件，对啊，做这件事根本没有所谓的规则手册。所以你基本上只能去问别人，你知道的，然后就像你刚才说的那样，怎么做这个？你是怎么做到的？同时还要尽量让自己看起来不像个笨蛋。好吧，我记得我曾为了工作搬到伦敦住过六个月，待了六个月。我当时有两个小孩子。我女儿才七个月大。我儿子三岁。所以我先飞过去了，因为我得去做额外的试装之类的东西。我还得给我们找套公寓，还得把家具置办好。
And so I remember I was standing in line at IKEA in London, like ordering a crib, trying to figure out like when it could be delivered with my schedule. And I was like, is this what Angelina Jolie? Like she must have someone doing this. Like, is this how everyone's doing it? Yeah. They're just doing it themselves. Yeah, that's how we do it. Exactly. This is maybe why we're best friends because we never consider not doing it ourselves. So then we are the person walking through the airport with seven garment bags and a steamer hoping that we brought the right shoes for when we get there.
所以我记得我当时在伦敦的宜家排队，比如在订婴儿床，还一边琢磨着它什么时候能按照我的日程安排送货。当时我就在想，安吉丽娜·朱莉也会这样吗？她肯定有专门的人来做这事吧？难道所有人都是这么干的？对啊。他们就是自己动手。对，这就是我们做事的方式。没错。这或许就是我们能成为死党的原因，因为我们从来没考虑过不自己动手。所以最后我们就是那个拖着七个服装袋和一个挂烫机走过机场的人，还祈祷着等到了目的地能穿对鞋子。
Yeah. Because we just, I don't know. Yeah, I forgot my shoes on a recent trip to New York to be on a TV show. I didn't even tell you this, Jenna. This happened again? This happened before. I guess I've done it a few times. This happened once when I was with you.
对啊。因为我们就是，我不知道。对啊，我最近去纽约上一个电视节目时就把鞋子落下了。我甚至都没告诉你这个，珍娜。这事又发生了？以前发生过这事。我想我已经犯过好几次了。有一次我和你在一起时就发生过这事。
I had dress pants and a blouse, and I had hiking boots. Is that what you wore? Oh, and a pair of really old, but like not your cute sneakers, like your old run-around-town sneakers. Sure. To have a stain on like the white part that you couldn't get out. Sure. What'd you do? I wore my sneakers, and I said, can you not get my feet?
我穿着正装裤和衬衫，还穿着一双登山靴。你当时就穿这个？哦，还有一双非常旧的，可不是那种可爱的运动鞋，而是那种你平时在城里到处跑着穿的旧运动鞋。没错。白色部分甚至还有一块洗不掉的污渍。没错。你当时怎么办的？我穿着运动鞋，然后我说：你们能不能别拍我的脚？
Well, next. Ted and Esmeralda are really mad that they're not sitting with the rest of their team at the head table, but instead they are seated at, I guess, what they're considering the kids' table. Right. Because that's where Adam and his wife are. And then Adelola and Travis come over, and they are clearly babysitting. Adam and his wife's kids. They bring the kids.
好吧，接下来。特德和埃斯梅拉达非常生气，因为他们没有和团队的其他人坐在一起，而是被安排坐在了，我猜他们认为是小孩的那一桌。没错。因为亚当和他的妻子就坐在那儿。然后阿德洛拉和特拉维斯走了过来，他们明显是在帮忙照看亚当和她妻子的孩子。他们把孩子也带来了。
I would be so pissed. Well, she is pissed. She's just like, what the fuck? What are you doing here with Archie? children and our baby. Yeah. One of the things that really cracked me up, though, so, you know, Travis is obsessed with Mare's Date.
我要是这样绝对会气疯的。好吧，她确实气疯了。她大概就是：他妈的怎么回事？你把阿奇带到这儿来干嘛？还有这些孩子和我们的宝宝。对啊。不过，真正让我笑喷的一点是，你知道的，特拉维斯对梅尔的约会对象着迷得不行。
We find out Mare's Date is Theo. They go way back. Theo rolls Cole. He's like a YouTuber, but he does like stupid stuff with his truck. But I loved this moment. He's like so impressed with Mare's Date that he wakes up a sleeping baby to be like, hey, look at this YouTube video, to the baby. Did you see that?
我们发现梅尔的约会对象是西奥。他们俩很有渊源。西奥很崇拜科尔。他就像是个油管博主，不过他老是开着他的卡车搞一些蠢事。但我超级喜欢这个桥段。他竟然对梅尔的约会对象佩服得五体投地，甚至还把一个熟睡的婴儿给弄醒，就为了对婴儿说：嘿，快看这个油管视频。你看到那个了吗？
Yes. And then I did call. that was a real baby that he woke up, but then it immediately cuts to him holding faky baby, four minutes, 56 seconds. Fanky baby. Faky baby. Are you guys big? Like, you catch those because I catch a fake baby.
看到了。然后我还特意查了一下，那确实是个被他弄醒的真婴儿，但紧接着镜头立刻切到了他抱着假婴儿的画面，在第四分五十六秒。假婴儿。假婴儿。你们对这个敏感吗？你们能一眼看出来吗，因为我能看出那是假婴儿。
Immediately. Immediately. That's like one of my things. It's the hair. It's the hair. Yeah. It's, yeah, it's, I always catch those too. Faky baby.
一眼就能看出。一眼就能。这简直是我的特长之一。是头发。就是头发。对。就是，对，我总是能一眼看出来。假婴儿。
Faky baby. Also, if the actor is moving a lot and the baby isn't, you know, the actor's like trying to look like. Yeah. But if they're standing still, then that's real baby. But that whole scene was so funny, though. And I love the addition of Theo mixing things up. Yeah, it was so fun to bring in Theo and in that whole dynamic, we had a lot of fun.
假婴儿。另外，如果演员在大幅度走动而婴儿一动不动，你知道的，演员就试图装作。是的。但如果他们站着不动，那这就是个真婴儿。不过整场戏真是太搞笑了。而且我超喜欢西奥加入进来把事情搅浑的设定。对啊，把西奥引入这场戏并融入整个动态真的太有意思了，我们当时拍得很开心。
Oh my gosh. And Maher's like, is Ned jealous? Yeah. Yeah. She's playing the game. She knows what she's doing. But getting to have Chris there, who's on the bear and also amazing, he was just so funny and like added so much to those scenes of just like this tension between us, which whatever, I'll get into.
天哪。而且梅尔还问：内德吃醋了吗？对啊。对啊。她在玩心理战。她知道自己在做什么。不过能让克里斯加入进来，他在《熊家餐馆》里演得超棒，他真是太搞笑了，为这些场景增添了太多色彩，那种我们之间剑拔弩张的紧张感，不管怎样，我等会儿会细说。
But I just. of everybody involved. I want to say everybody's name. This is what I would say, number one, of Mayer's dreamy eye look. There's a lot of dreamy eyes. You have a lot of, like, yeah, like real pretty eye looks to camera, like, I don't know, let's say it up for them.
但我只是。所有参与其中的人。我想说出每个人的名字。如果让我排第一，我会说这是梅尔梦幻般的眼神。有很多梦幻的眼神。你有很多，比如，对，对着镜头做出那种超级漂亮的眼神，就像是，我不知道，让我们为他们奠定基调吧。
I don't know. I get really embarrassed watching the finale, because I do, I think she's a really, I think it's been like a season of her kind of like trying to keep whatever she's feeling at bay. And I remember, like, we just talked about it of like, kind of, like, you just got to, go for it. And something about that, this whole episode feels kind of like dreamy and just not like real life, I think for her. And so, yeah, the dreamy eyes were, I think I was, yeah, it was just a,
我不知道。看大结局的时候我真的觉得很尴尬，因为我确实觉得，我觉得这好像是她一直在努力克制自己内心情感的一季。我记得，就像我们刚才谈到的，就好像，你只能，放手去搏。而且关于这一点，整集节目给人的感觉都有点像是在做梦，我觉得对她来说这很不现实。所以，是的，那些梦幻的眼神，我想当时我是，是的，那只是一种，
it always felt a little like removed from the paper and like what's happening back at the office. But that's what those nights are like. Yes, they're intoxicating. Yeah. You're dressed up. Yeah. Nobody's seen you dressed up before. Yeah. Maris having a lot of wine. A lot. Yeah. And a martini will get. get to it. What about your outfit? I want to talk about it. Because you have on this sort of like lace kind of boostier and a beautiful kind of satin
总是让人感觉有点脱离现实，也脱离了办公室里正在发生的事情。但那些夜晚就是这样的。没错，它们令人陶醉。对啊。你盛装打扮。对啊。从来没有人见过你盛装打扮的样子。对啊。梅尔喝了好多酒。喝了很多。对啊。还有一杯马提尼，绝对能让你。进入状态。那你的服装呢？我想聊聊这个。因为你穿着这种类似蕾丝的紧身胸衣和一件漂亮的绸缎
blouse. But the blouse, it shifts. And we see more boostier, less boostier. Yes, yes. It was such the perfect to me, mayor choice. Because the other time we've seen you dressed up is when you're going undercover. Yeah. But that really didn't feel like mayor, right?
衬衫。但是这件衬衫，它是会移位的。我们时而看到更多的胸衣，时而看到更少的胸衣。对，对。在我看来，这绝对是极其完美的梅尔式的选择。因为我们之前见你盛装打扮的时候，都是在你要去卧底的时候。对。但那真的不像是梅尔会穿的，对吧？
No, no. She was playing a character. I believe that came out of Esmerald's closet. personally. 100%. And threw it on mayor. But this is Mayor's closet, and this is how Mayor dresses up, and I loved it. I loved this look.
不，不。她那是在扮演一个角色。我个人觉得那肯定是出自埃斯梅拉达的衣橱。百分之百。然后硬套在了梅尔身上。但这才是梅尔的衣橱，这才是梅尔盛装打扮的方式，我太喜欢了。我超爱这个造型。
I loved the peek-a-boo. It was so great. Thank you. Yeah, I remember Kathleen and I tried on a few different things, and we tried on some dresses, and we were just like, this just doesn't feel like her. It just never felt right. Because we were like, yeah, we want to see her try in a way that she doesn't at the office. And, yeah, exactly that.
我太喜欢这种犹抱琵琶半遮面的感觉了。太棒了。谢谢。对，我记得我和凯瑟琳试了好几种不同的搭配，我们试过一些裙子，然后我们俩就觉得，这根本不符合她的风格。感觉总是不太对劲。因为我们觉得，对啊，我们想看到她做出一种在办公室里绝不会有的尝试。而且，对，就是那种感觉。
like getting to see Ned and everybody else outside of the office. Clearly, she's going to put thought into it. But a dress never felt right. Something that felt like a little worky, but also like a little boostier, exactly. There was something that felt really right about it. But we talked about it a long time. Kathleen's just, yeah, she's amazing. Well, I remember that with Pam, like picking, what is the thing she's going to wear on casino night? This is. Yeah. And her hair. Yes. And like Mary, a big moment's going to happen. It was that dress. It's like like a, Like lilac. Yeah.
就像有机会看到内德和其他人在办公室之外的样子。很显然，她会对穿着精挑细选一番。但裙子总让人觉得不对劲。那种既带点工作装的感觉，但又有点紧身胸衣风的衣服，简直绝了。那种感觉真的恰到好处。但我们为此讨论了很久。凯瑟琳真的是，对啊，她太棒了。哦，我记得帕姆也是这样，比如挑选，她在赌场之夜要穿什么衣服？这是。对。还有她的头发。没错。就像玛丽一样，一个重大时刻要发生了。就是那条裙子。就像是一条，像丁香紫。对。
It's like that little shimmery-ish. Yeah. So pretty. Our whole thing was that it was a bridesmaid's dress she wore for someone's wedding. Stop it. Perfect. And that just gave me chills. I love that fact.
就那种有点微闪的。对。超级漂亮。我们对它的整个设定是，那是她以前去参加别人的婚礼时穿过的伴娘裙。别闹了。太完美了。这简直让我起了一身鸡皮疙瘩。我太喜欢这个设定了。
Yeah. And because we were like, why does she have this dress? And we're like, what if she repurposes a bridesmaid's dress? They always say you can wear it again and you never do. Totally. Totally. You can wear it again. Where?
对。因为我们当时在想，她为什么会有这条裙子？然后我们就在想，如果她把一条伴娘裙重新拿来改改穿呢？人们总是说这裙子以后还能穿，但你从来没再穿过。完全是这样。完全是这样。你还能再穿它。去哪儿穿？
Where am I wearing this again? Where am I wearing this tavern? That's so true. Wow, that's great. Well, another storyline we haven't talked about yet is about to get set up. It's the Nicole Detrick storyline. Guess who else is at this event? It's the weather girl. Yeah. The meteorologist who he has supposedly also been dating. He talked about her way back when. And Nicole's like, oh my gosh, look who's here. And she's hot. And Detrick's like, sure. Sure, sure. Well, as it turns out, Dendrick has not been dating her. Nicole goes over and talks to her. And this woman, we never hear this conversation, but clearly it went something like, what are you talking about? I'm not dating him. Yeah. And Nicole gets super upset. She's like, you tricked me into dating you? Into a monogamous relationship. How dare you? You're such a dog, so loyal. Yeah. And then he's like, I kind of, you know, was hoping for that. And then he breaks up with her.
我到底要在哪个酒馆穿这玩意儿？太真实了。哇，太棒了。好吧，另一个我们还没聊过的故事情节也即将铺陈开来。那就是妮可·德特里克的故事线。猜猜还有谁也出席了这个活动？天气女孩。对。那个据传他一直在跟她约会的那个气象播报员。他很久以前就提起过她。妮可就说：哦，天哪，快看谁来了。而且她身材火辣。德特里克就说：当然。当然，当然。好吧，事实证明，邓德里克根本没有和她约会。妮可走过去跟她聊了起来。这个女人，我们虽然没听到这段对话，但显然谈话内容类似于：你在胡说八道什么？我才没跟他约会呢。对。然后妮可超级难过。她就说：你竟然骗我跟你约会？还骗我进入一段一夫一妻制的恋爱关系？你怎么敢的？你这个十足的混蛋，这么不忠诚。对。然后他就说：我当时，你知道的，确实挺希望能这样的。接着他就把她给甩了。
I mean, what's up with that? What is going to happen with them? Without giving too much away, it's exciting to see how their relationship progresses. I mean, I love them both so much. Ramona and Melvin, they're just so funny in their own very specific ways. Oh, yeah. And specifically Ramona. I will say this.
我的天，这算怎么回事啊？他们俩接下来会怎么样？在不剧透太多的前提下，看他们的感情如何发展真的挺让人兴奋的。我是说，我太喜欢他们俩了。拉莫娜和梅尔文，他们以各自非常独特的方式承包了所有的笑点。哦，对。尤其是拉莫娜。我得这么说。
I like the character of Nicole. I don't like Nicole with Detrick. Oh, interesting. But I do relate to Nicole as someone who played a character who wasn't great to the men in her life. Andy Bernard, you know, and then, my gosh, the whole Dwight and Angela thing was so up and down and all over the place. So like, I think you were justified in a lot of your feelings during that. Thank you. You're welcome.
我喜欢妮可这个角色。但我不喜欢妮可和德特里克在一起。哦，有意思。但我确实能对妮可产生共鸣，因为我也曾饰演过一个对生命中的男人们不太好的角色。比如安迪·伯纳德，你知道的，然后，天哪，德怀特和安吉拉之间的种种简直是起起伏伏、乱七八糟。所以我觉得，你在经历这一切时，你的很多情绪都是情有可原的。谢谢你。不客气。
Thank you. But, yeah, but poor Andy. She wasn't great to Andy. Andy, that was tough. Yeah. Without giving anything away in season two, because this relationship ends on quite the emotional cliffhanger, the Dettrick and Nicole. Well, that's what I was going to say, that heartbreaking woman at the end. when she is crying in my hotel room at the end of the night.
谢谢。但是，唉，可怜的安迪。她对安迪可真不算好。安迪那段真是太难了。在不剧透第二季剧情的前提下，因为这段关系最终以一个相当戏剧化、充满情感悬念的方式结束了，也就是德特里克和妮可。哦，对了，我正想说呢，结尾时那个让人心碎的女人。当她在一天结束时坐在我的酒店房间里哭泣的时候。
It was so heartbreaking. And to me, it just felt so real of somebody who doesn't know what they want and aren't ready to commit either way, but also they just know they're sad. And I think that's like sometimes the only thing you know is the emotion you're feeling, but not exactly what to do with that emotion. Yeah, it was heartbreaking.
那真的太让人心碎了。对我来说，这感觉真实得可怕，完美展现了一个不知道自己想要什么、无论哪种选择都还没准备好承诺的人，但他们唯独知道自己很难过。我觉得有时候你唯一能确切感受到的，就只有你此刻的心情，却不知道该怎么去处理这种情绪。对啊，真的太让人心碎了。
It's a moment that isn't really seen on screen, but, you know, we were in there with her crying. and then I have to go out and when Ned gets there and everything. But yeah, my heart broke for her in that moment. So I was like, I know what you're going through. You don't know what you want, but this also sucks. Her performance is so good when she's crying. And it's such a hard thing because you're right.
这是一个在银幕上并不常见的时刻，但是，你知道的，我们当时陪着她一起哭泣。然后我还得走出去，正好赶上内德到达以及发生的一切。不过，是的，那一刻我的心都为她碎了。所以当时我就想，我懂你正在经历什么。你不知道自己想要什么，但这感觉也确实糟透了。她哭戏的演技简直太棒了。而且这真的很不容易，因为你说得对。
We don't see any of the lead up to it. It's just you open the door a little further. And she's kind of in the background, but sobbing. But like it's so good that you see how deeply she's feeling it. Yeah. So kudos to her. That's a way to go, Ramona. Yeah, she's amazing.
我们看不到任何导致这一幕发生的前情铺垫。就只是你把门再推开一点。然后她差不多是在背景里，但却在泣不成声。不过，你能深刻体会到她内心那种深切的悲伤，这真的演得太好了。所以，向她致敬。干得漂亮，拉莫娜。对，她太棒了。
She's amazing. I also think that's the genius of Greg and Michael. I feel like they're able to say so much with just these like little moments. Like the fact that you kind of totally know her arc with just that moment, it goes to, you know, the script and also just Ramona being able to play it with such gravity. Yeah. Yeah. She's good. I'm curious for season two.
她太棒了。我也觉得这就是格雷格和迈克尔的天才之处。我觉得他们总能仅凭这些微小的时刻表达出如此丰富的内容。比如仅仅通过那一幕，你就能完全了解她的人物成长弧光，这全归功于剧本，同时也归功于拉莫娜能够以如此厚重的演技将之完美呈现。对啊。对。她真的很棒。我很期待第二季。
Yeah. All right. So now the ceremony is starting. We're kind of going to go back to the original timeline here. And the host is talking. And there's this runner that starts that cracked me up. Esmeralda, she just wants to be in the room where it happens. Do you know what I mean? She wants to be at that head table so desperately. She approaches Marv with like such a lame conversation segue. I feel like I do this. I'm trying to work my way into like a conversation. I'm horrible at it. But she goes like this. I heard the. chef is from Chicago. How exciting is this evening. And then there's a little bit of Marf shade. He says, you know what? I'm happy to be back at the awards. It's been a few years. And he looks at Esmeralda and she fills the shade. And then Ken freaks out. He freaks out. It's so funny. He's like, I need to distance myself from Esmeralda. This is one of my favorite new expressions. He then says, I'm getting swept away in her mediocrity. It's kind of the same as like when you say, like, that person brings nothing to the table. It's like just so devastating.
好了。现在仪式要开始了。我们要把时间线拉回到最开始的节点。主持人在发言。然后有一个插曲让我笑喷了。埃斯梅拉达，她就是想挤进那个权力核心的房间。你知道我的意思吗？她做梦都想坐在主宾席上。她走向玛夫，搭话的切入点简直烂透了。我觉得我有时候也这样。我总想硬生生地切入别人的谈话。我在这方面糟糕透了。但她是这么说的：我听说主厨来自芝加哥。今晚的活动太令人兴奋了吧。然后玛夫就进行了一波微秒的嘲讽。他说：你知道吗？我很高兴能重返颁奖典礼。已经过去好几年了。然后他看了看埃斯梅拉达，她感受到了这种挖苦。接着肯就抓狂了。他彻底抓狂了。太搞笑了。他说：我得跟埃斯梅拉达保持距离。这是我最喜欢的全新表达之一。他接着说：我正在被她的平庸无能所吞噬。这感觉就有点像你说的，那个人毫无用处。这种评价简直太具毁灭性了。
It's like if you hear that about yourself, it's a day-ruiner. You're a ruiner. He goes on to say, a prestige shift is happening. Oscar now has the ear of Marv. It's a dangerous thing. Well, speaking of Oscar, the first award goes to Oscar on his new game. And Oscar dedicates his award to the documentary film crew. It's crazy.
这就好比如果你听到别人这样评价自己，这一天绝对就全毁了。你就是个毁人精。他接着说道：一场地位的更迭正在发生。奥斯卡现在成了玛夫身边的红人。这可不是什么好事。好吧，说到奥斯卡，第一个奖项颁给了凭借新游戏获奖的奥斯卡。而奥斯卡把他的奖项献给了纪录片摄制组。这太疯狂了。
Well, we actually had a lot of fans right in about this moment. Jamie B. in Oklahoma loved that he acknowledged the camera crew. And then also Thomas S. from Sydney, Australia, said, something I would love to hear discussed is, do you think Oscar's colleagues in Toledo have seen the Office and American Workplace documentary? Did you guys ever talk about that? Wow, that is so interesting because no, we didn't.
其实我们收到了很多粉丝关于这一刻的来信。俄克拉荷马州的杰米·B就特别喜欢他向摄影团队致谢的举动。还有来自澳大利亚悉尼的托马斯·S说：我一直很想听你们讨论的一个问题是，你们觉得奥斯卡在托利多的同事们看过《办公室》和《美国职场》这部纪录片吗？你们以前讨论过这个吗？哇，这太有意思了，因为没有，我们从没讨论过。
And I don't think they have. I think that would be, gosh, I don't know. Because the camera crew is there and Oscar knows them. So I feel like at some point, the Toledo Truth Teller employees would be like, why do they know you? That is such a good point. I don't know if we would have seen it. I don't think mayor would. I think it would freak her out.
而且我觉得他们没看过。我觉得那会，天哪，我不知道。因为摄影团队就在那儿，而且奥斯卡认识他们。所以我觉得在某个时间点，托利多“实话实说”公司的员工肯定会问：为什么他们认识你？这真是个绝佳的切入点。我不知道我们有没有可能看到它。我觉得梅尔不会看。我觉得这会把她吓坏的。
I don't think Merwood. I could see Esmeralda maybe Googling him or looking him up online. But I don't think that documentary would have been on Merr's radar for sure. No, I don't think so. That's funny. My feeling is that nobody there had seen it, which is why Oscar was so upset to see the documentary crew again. Because he had managed to, you know,
我觉得梅尔不会看。我能想象到埃斯梅拉达可能会去谷歌搜索他或者在网上人肉他。但我觉得这部纪录片绝对不会进入梅尔的雷达范围。不，我觉得不会。太逗了。我的感觉是那里没有人看过，这也是为什么奥斯卡再次看到纪录片摄制组时会那么生气。因为他好不容易才设法，你知道的，
there was some notoriety for everybody right when this documentary came out. But I could also see how, like, I know for Andy it was a little bit more national. but like I think like in general for the other people, it was probably more like Scranton took an interest in this documentary about their local business. And I think Oscar moving away was him wanting to get away from all of that. So he had been living a kind of more anonymous life that he was very happy with. Yeah.
在这部纪录片刚上映时，每个人都获得了一定的知名度。但我也能理解，比如我知道对安迪来说这种全国知名度更高一点，但我觉得对其他人来说，可能更像是斯克兰顿对这部关于他们当地企业的纪录片产生了兴趣。而我觉得奥斯卡搬走就是为了逃离这一切。所以他当时过着一种更加匿名、他自己也非常满意的生活。对啊。
Which is I think why, you know, when they show up again, he's so mad. And, you know, I can't imagine that when he went to work there, anybody was like, hey, I saw you in that documentary. Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah. I think if anyone, one or two people found out after the fact. But I did love in his acceptance speech. It was very finer things club to me where he was like, well, I guess I'm just meant to be the subject of the documentary. He was all, I remember that speech when he, because, you know, we all got to sit and watch it so many times.
我想这也是为什么当他们再次出现时，他会那么生气。而且，我简直无法想象当他在那里工作时，会有人对他说：嘿，我在那部纪录片里看到过你。对，对，对，对。我觉得即使有，也是一两个人事后才发现的。但我真的很喜欢他的获奖感言。我觉得这非常有“精英俱乐部”的感觉，当时他说的是：好吧，我想我注定只能成为纪录片的拍摄对象了。我记得他发表那段演讲时的样子，因为，你知道的，我们所有人都坐着看了那么多遍。
He's so great. He's always so funny. But there was also just such a level of like vulnerability when he gave that speech. that was so sweet, you don't always get to see with that character. And it was just so great every single time. Yeah. Yeah. He crushed it.
他太棒了。他总是那么搞笑。但当他发表那段演讲时，字里行间也流露出了一种脆弱感，真的非常温馨，你并不总能在那个角色身上看到这一面。每一次看都觉得太棒了。对啊。对。他演得太绝了。
Speaking of speeches, we're about to hear from Mare. Yeah. Chelsea, chef's kiss. Oh, thank you. To all of it. But Mare wins. Everybody goes wild. I love your choice of kind of looking down,
说到获奖感言，我们马上要听到梅尔的发言了。对啊。切尔西，简直是主厨之吻般的完美。哦，谢谢。所有的一切。但梅尔获奖了。全场瞬间沸腾。我特别喜欢你的那个设计，先是假装往下看，
and then they announced the name, and then the look on your face. It was all so. real. And then the way you, everybody just is piling together and hugging. And it's like, it is, you guys all lose your shit. And Jenna and I were saying it did remind us of like when Steve won the Golden Globe. We lost our shit. We did. We were at a very fancy party. We weren't allowed inside of the Golden Globes. We were the party adjacent. Sure. Okay. A tinted parking lot. Hilarious. But he won and no one was expecting it. And we lost. our minds. Yeah. I have a picture of Jenna and David Denman like doubled over, like yelling that I'll never forget. But yet, your performance was so honest. And I remember like when I
然后他们宣读了名字，接着是你脸上的表情。这一切都太真实了。然后你们那种所有人都堆叠在一起疯狂拥抱的方式。那种感觉就是，你们所有人都彻底失控了。我和珍娜当时就说，这真的让我们想起史蒂夫赢得金球奖时的场景。我们当时也彻底失控了。确实如此。我们当时在一个非常高级的派对上。我们没被允许进入金球奖的内场。我们是派对外围的人。没错。好吧。一个有色玻璃窗的停车场。太搞笑了。但他获奖了，而且所有人都没有预料到。我们彻底情绪失控了。我有张照片，上面是珍娜和大卫·德曼笑得前仰后合、放声尖叫的样子，我永远不会忘记。但是，你的表演真的太真诚了。我记得当我
watched it, I was like, yes, I was so excited. I was so excited you won. Thank you. How was that? You know, it's so funny because it really was nerve-wracking. It was a room of like 200 people, including all the crew, but, you know, all the background actors, everybody from our cast. And you got to get up there and also remember your lines and it was a crazy week where we had a lot to memorize and so there is a part of you like okay I need to make sure I know this speech yeah and so I do remember like I got out there and I would just get so nervous and like hot and my heart would start fluttering and I was like oh my god I really do feel like I'm giving a speech in front of everybody and it's terrifying and also just the fact that mayor has come this far in this season of you know she always wanted to be a reporter
看着它的时候，我就想，是的，我太激动了。我太高兴你获奖了。谢谢你。当时感觉怎么样？你知道，这太搞笑了，因为真的很伤脑筋。那是一个大约有 200 人的房间，包括所有的剧组人员，还有所有的群众演员，我们剧组的每个人。你得站上去，还得记住你的台词，而且这是一个疯狂的周，我们有很多东西要背，所以你心里有一部分会想，好吧，我需要确保我知道这个演讲，是的，所以我确实记得，就像我走出去的时候，我就会变得非常紧张，而且很热，我的心开始扑通扑通地跳，我就想，哦，天哪，我真的觉得自己是在所有人面前做演讲，这太可怕了，而且事实上，梅尔在这一季中走到了这一步，你知道她一直想成为一名记者
kind of gave up that dream and the way Ned reignites this love she has for journalism to culminate in her winning this award for a story where she really could have gotten fired and lost her job and is kind of going against the man. It was so fun.
可以说是放弃了那个梦想，而内德重新点燃了她对新闻的热爱，最终让她因一篇差点被解雇、丢掉饭碗、有点对抗体制的报道而赢得这个奖项。这太有趣了。
It was so fun. I feel like I did win the award. It's in my house. Oh, we wanted to ask you if you got to keep it. Of course. Taylor Improps is amazing. And yeah, He knew how much it meant to me, and he gave that to me.
这太有趣了。我觉得我真的得奖了。它就在我家。哦，我们想问你是不是把它留作纪念了。当然。泰勒·因普罗普斯太棒了。而且，是的，他知道这对我有多少意义，他把它给了我。
But, yeah, the other thing they gave me were Ned's speech that he wrote me. Aw, the cards. Yeah, at the end, he really wrote me something, which was very sweet. And... Chelsea, this is giving me chills. You know, there's this moment where Ned gives you his speech that he was going to say and has all these heartfelt things to you, but you read them. To yourself.
但是，是的，他们给我的另一件事是内德写给我的演讲词。啊，那些卡片。是的，最后，他真的给我写了一些东西，非常甜蜜。而且……切尔西，这让我起鸡皮疙瘩。你知道，有这样一个时刻，内德把他的演讲词交给你，那是他原本要说的话，里面有所有对你发自内心的感慨，但你读了它们。在心里。
To yourself. And it brought back teapot-fi. for me. When Jim finally gives Pam the teapot note, we never reveal what was really in it. You just, like you, just see Pam react
在心里。这让我回想起“茶壶情结”。当吉姆终于把茶壶纸条给帕姆时，我们从未透露里面到底写了什么。你只是，就像你一样，你只能看到帕姆的反应
to what was written. And John really wrote me something. Really? And I treasure it. I'm going to cry. You do. Yes. I have my cards. And to Donald's credit, and I would tell him 99% positive, this is how it went, but the original script, he did say something to me.
对于所写的内容。约翰真的给我写了东西。真的吗？我珍藏着它。我要哭了。你确实如此。是的。我有我的卡片。为了给唐纳尔作证，我会99%肯定地告诉他，事情就是这样的，但最初的剧本中，他对我说了一些话。
He said the speech to me. He said the speech to me. in that scene. And Donnell said, would you mind if we tried one where Chelsea just read something I write to her? And they were like, yeah, and we ended up doing that
他对我说了一段台词。他对我说了一段台词。在那场戏里。唐纳尔说，如果你不介意的话，我们能不能试着拍一场由切尔西来读我写给她的东西的戏？他们说，行，我们最后真的这么做了
for rehearsal, and it just felt so much better. And yeah, he wrote me something, and it was like, I had no idea what it was going to be. And he gave me a different one, so every single time I got to react to something different.
为了排练，感觉好多了。是的，他给我写了一些东西，就像我完全不知道会是什么内容。而且他给了我一份不同的，所以每一次我都能对不同的内容做出反应。
Oh, my goodness. That is so thoughtful. He's good. He's amazing. And I just told Taylor, I was like, can I have those? I was like, yes. So I kept them.
哦，天哪。这太贴心了。他真棒。他太棒了。我刚对泰勒说，我说，我能把那些留着吗？我说，可以。所以我把它们留下了。
You know, though, that's just a great scene partner because that's a gift for your performance. It is. Truly, truly is. And he is so busy. He has so much to do on our show. He's such a great leader. I could talk about Donnell Forever. But he's such an incredible scene partner.
你知道吗，这真是一个伟大的搭档，因为这对你的表演来说是一份厚礼。确实是。真的，真的是。而且他太忙了。他在我们的节目里有那么多事情要做。他是个如此出色的领导者。我可以没完没了地谈论唐纳尔。但他真是个不可思议的搭档。
Like so giving, so present makes me so much better. I feel like I'm like learning from him every day. It's truly like of all the gifts of the show getting to work with him is really. it's up there. You guys are a great pair. You really are. Thanks. I had a question, though, about your speech, which is your walk up to the stage,
就像那么无私，那么投入，让我变得更好。我觉得我每天都在向他学习。这真的是，在节目的所有收获中，能与他合作真的是，首屈一指。你们真是一对绝配。你们真的是。谢谢。不过我有个关于你演讲的问题，就是你走上舞台的时候，
Esmeralda stops mirror. And she's like, wait a day! She grabbed your hands. Was that choreographed or just like, did you just find it on the day? We talked to, there was a bit of choreography with like which way. It was always like she's going to try and stop you, but it changed a few times of like how that's going to happen. And that is truly the fun of Sabrina is like the physical comedy is so fun that you just have to respond in the moment.
埃斯梅拉达拦住了梅尔。她说，等一下！她抓住了你的手。那是编排好的，还是当场即兴发挥的？我们讨论过，确实有一些关于走哪个方向的编排。剧本里一直写着她会试图阻止你，但具体怎么做改了好几次。这真的是萨布丽娜的有趣之处，肢体喜剧太有趣了，你只需要当下做出反应。
I mean, I knew it wasn't a surprise to you, but you look as Mary, you look surprised. Like, oh my God, how do I get out of this? But it's, that's so funny that she changed it up each time. Yeah, it was amazing. It was so fun. But yes, yeah, she was really trying to stop me from getting up there. And nothing was going to stop me. Well, I think we should take a quick break.
我的意思是，我知道这对你来说不是惊喜，但你看着埃斯梅拉达，看起来很惊讶。就像，哦，天哪，我怎么摆脱这个？不过，她每次都换花样，这太有趣了。是的，太棒了。太好玩了。但是，是的，是的，她真的在试图阻止我走上去。没有什么能阻止我。嗯，我想我们该休息一下了。
And then we come back. We're going to really dig into this. Kiss and a number of other things. There's more to this story. There is. And maybe, just maybe you'll hear, Asmorelda, sing a song about dead journalists. We'll be right back. You guys, we are back.
等我们回来。我们要深入探讨这个。吻以及其他很多事情。这个故事还有更多内容。确实有。也许，只是也许你会听到，埃斯梅拉达唱一首关于死去的记者的歌。我们马上回来。各位，我们回来了。
And I think you all need to hear something. What's going to happen at the ceremony now is this in-memorium, right? The journalists that have passed on, there's going to be that classic slideshow with music playing in the background. And as everyone's watching this, And, you know, giving their respects to these journalists who have passed, Esmeralda sees her moment. She's going to approach the stage. She takes the microphone.
我想你们都需要听听这个。接下来仪式上要发生的是这个缅怀环节，对吧？那些逝去的记者，会有那个播放着背景音乐的经典幻灯片。当每个人都在观看这个的时候，你知道，向这些逝去的记者表达敬意，埃斯梅拉达看到了她的时机。她走上舞台。她拿起了话筒。
She begins this impromptu song. It's, oh, Lord, we need to hear it. Yeah, we do. My colleagues, keep playing, Maestro. My name is Esmeralda Grand, and I'm so very sad for all these. these dead people. It's so sad to be that.
她开始唱这首即兴歌曲。天哪，我们需要听听它。对，我们必须听。我的同事们，继续弹奏，大师。我叫埃斯梅拉达·格兰德，我为所有人感到非常难过。这些死去的灵魂。真难过啊。
Oh, sad that journalist you made your final deadline. Oh, yes, please, respect to the dead. Sad dead journalist you are gone and no one will read you anymore. anymore. Thank you. Touch you guys. Your reaction to it
哦，真难过，记者你迎来了最后的截稿期限。哦，是的，拜托，向死者致敬。悲伤的已故记者，你已经离去，再也没有人会阅读你的作品了。谢谢。感动到你们了。你们的反应
is so damn funny. Everybody is cringing so hard. You have this look to camera that's hilarious. I need to back up to the table read for this episode when this moment came up. Does she sing during the table read?
太好笑了。每个人都尴尬得要死。你对着镜头露出了一个搞笑的表情。我需要倒回这场戏的剧本围读，当时这个时刻出现的时候。她在围读时唱歌了吗？
Oh my gosh. Do you remember? I don't think she did, but I remember hearing the idea of it and knowing that she was going to do it and that's kind of the more exciting thing about Sabrina. A lot of the times, like, you'll get a version of it during a table read, but you're also like, this is going to be.
哦，天哪。你还记得吗？我想她没有唱，但我记得听到过这个点子，知道她要这么做，这正是萨布丽娜最令人兴奋的地方。很多时候，你在围读时会听到一个版本，但你也会想，这将会是……
It could be anything. It could be anything once we get there. Yeah, that was a very fun day. Did it change? Did she throw in different things, or was it pretty much the same song? It was a lot of the same song. I remember she was incredibly nervous going into it. Sure.
一旦我们到了现场，什么都可能发生。是的，那真是非常有趣的一天。有改变吗？她加了不同的东西吗，还是基本上是同一首歌？大部分还是那首歌。我记得她进去的时候紧张得无以复加。那是当然。
And it's so funny because she's such like a larger-than-life person, but she's also so sweet. and has this heart of gold and also just like gets and can is vulnerable like all of us. And she's like, I have to do this song in front of all of you and all this choreography and everything. And she she crushed it every single time. Yeah. It was so fun to watch. I had to sing Little Drummer Boy in front of everybody.
这太搞笑了，因为她平时是一个充满活力的人，但她也非常甜美，拥有一颗金子般的心，而且像我们一样能够敞开心扉、展露脆弱。她说，我必须在你们所有人面前唱这首歌，还有所有的舞蹈动作和一切。而她每一次都完美驾驭。是的。看她表演太有趣了。我曾在所有人面前唱过《小鼓手男孩》。
Oh my God. So good. Jenna knows. I hate singing. I was terrified. I was terrified. But I mean, you would never know Sabrina had that that shyness because the way Asmorelida comes to life.
哦，天哪。太棒了。詹娜知道。我讨厌唱歌。我当时吓坏了。我吓坏了。但是我的意思是，你绝对看不出萨布丽娜有那种羞涩，因为埃斯梅拉达被赋予生命的方式。
It's perfect. She transformed. It's perfect. It's amazing. Well, after this wonderful dedication to the journalists that have passed on, Mare and Ned are going to sneak away because Mare says, I think you should be prepared to win. I know you're acting like you're not going to win or you don't care if you win, but I think you are going to win. Now, they've already won two awards. She says, let's go practice your speech.
太完美了。她蜕变了。太完美了。太棒了。好了，在对逝去记者致以这番精彩的悼词之后，梅尔和内德偷偷溜走了，因为梅尔说，我想你应该做好获胜的准备。我知道你表现得好像不会赢，或者不在乎是否赢得这个奖，但我觉得你会赢的。现在，他们已经赢得了两个奖项。她说，我们去练习你的演讲吧。
I want to hear it. So they sneak off. But then this turns into sneaking into a wedding. You guys crash a wedding. Crash a wedding. And then he's like dancing together. And then like he's kind of practicing the speech, but you're also dancing, dancey, dancey, flirty.
我想听听。于是他们偷偷溜走了。但这随后变成了潜入一场婚礼。你们大闹婚礼。大闹婚礼。然后他们一起跳舞。然后他一边练习演讲，但你们也在跳舞、跳舞、跳舞，调情。
A guy walks by with champagne, you grab a glass. Mary has been drinking at this point. Oh, yeah. You did some really good, subtle, drunky acting in this episode. Well done. Thank you. It's not easy to do. It's not. I feel like the less you try and think about it, the better it kind of is.
一个拿着香槟的家伙走过，你抢了一杯。梅尔此时已经喝了酒。哦，是的。你在这一集里演了一些非常出色、微妙的醉酒状态。干得漂亮。谢谢。这可不容易做到。确实不易。我觉得你越是不去刻意想它，效果反而越好。
She's many you start playing drunk. It's tough. Oh, yeah. And you're getting like the liquid courage. Like that's the drunky acting that I really liked. Like the slow song comes on and you can tell like, she's a little buzz. She's going to go for the slow dance. Yeah. I think at a certain point she has to. I think she knows he's never going to act on this. And I think at this point she just wants acknowledgement. Or the mystery, like, what is this? What is this? Whatever it is, I just need to know what it is.
一旦你开始刻意去演醉酒，那就很难了。哦，是的。你在借酒壮胆。这就是我真的很喜欢的醉酒演技。就像慢歌响起时，你能看出，她有点微醺。她要去跳慢舞了。对。我想在某种程度上她必须这么做。我想她知道他永远不会主动采取行动。我想此时她只是想要一个明确的态度。或者那个谜题，比如，这到底是什么？这到底是什么？不管是什么，我只是需要知道那是什么。
Yeah. I think it's such a fine line because they are so in love with the paper and so focused on it and so happy to have each other in this journey. And I think at this point, she too is questioning, like, am I making up any other sort of feelings around him? Is it just that we're really good friends and colleagues and want to make this thing work? is it one-sided. So yeah, and I think she's so still, like, bubbling with this high of winning the award that she kind of feels like anything could happen. She has that body buzz.
是的。我认为这是一条非常微妙的界限，因为他们都太热爱报社了，太专注于此，而且很高兴能在这段旅程中拥有彼此。我想此时，她也在反思，我是不是对他产生了其他什么多余的感情？难道我们只是很好的朋友和同事，只想把这件事做好？这只是我一厢情愿吗？所以，是的，而且我觉得她仍然沉浸在获奖的狂喜中，以至于她觉得任何事情都有可能发生。她有那种全身飘飘然的感觉。
Yeah. All of that. Yeah. Yeah. Well, guess what? What? They do win. And you guys aren't there.
是的。所有这些。是的。好吧，你猜怎么着？什么？他们真的获奖了。而你们不在场。
You're not in the room. So Esmerald and Ken start to accept the award in the cringiest moment of the episode. deliciously cringy. I mean, there's a few, but this is in the top five. Yes. And then you pry open a kitchen door, which is amazing. I loved all of this. This is great physical comedy, and he sort of slips in on his stomach,
你们不在房间里。所以埃斯梅拉达和肯开始领奖，这是全剧最尴尬的时刻。令人愉悦的尴尬。我的意思是，有很多，但这绝对排进前五。是的。然后你撬开了一扇厨房的门，这太棒了。我太喜欢这一切了。这是绝佳的肢体喜剧，他有点顺着肚子滑了进去，
and then Ned finally gets to go up to give his speech. But before he can finish his speech, before he gets to the good stuff. Right. Asmeralda faints. In quotes. In quotes. And then that's it. Like everyone rushes the stage.
然后内德终于可以上台发表获奖感言了。但在他说完演讲之前，在他切入正题之前。没错。埃斯梅拉达晕倒了。打了引号的。打了引号的。然后就这样了。就像所有人冲上舞台。
Pivot to after the ceremony. You guys are having a little after party. Yes. And it's very sweet. Nicole is going to tell Mayor that Detrick broke up with her, but she's totally fine. Yeah. And she's just going to leave to go change her clothes, no big whoop. Until she looks across the bar and sees him talking to another lady.
镜头切换到颁奖典礼之后。你们在开一个小型的庆功派对。是的。非常温馨。妮可告诉梅尔，迪特里克和她分手了，但她完全没事。是的。她只是要去换身衣服，没什么大不了的。直到她抬头隔着酒吧看到他在跟另一个女士说话。
Yeah. And now this is what's going to make her cry in the hotel room. That's right. Yes. And then Ned comes and joins Mary. and Mary's having her martini, two olives. Uh-huh. And he says that everyone just looks magnificent, you know, in the light of the Preston Hotel, I guess.
是的。现在，这就是让她在酒店房间里哭泣的原因。没错了。是的。然后内德过来找梅尔，而梅尔正在喝她的两颗橄榄马蒂尼。嗯哼。他说每个人看起来都光彩照人，你知道的，在普雷斯顿酒店的灯光下，我猜。
And Mary's like, are you trying to tell me I look magnificent? And then Theo interrupts them. And so Ned leaves. And now we see Esmeralda and Ned at the bar. I do love this. This is a callback to earlier in the season. Esmeralda is holding a glass of champagne, and it is covered with. red lipstick.
梅尔就说，你是在暗示我看起来光彩照人吗？然后西奥打断了他们。于是内德离开了。现在我们看到埃斯梅拉达和内德在酒吧。我真的很喜欢这个。这是对本季早期情节的回应。埃斯梅拉达拿着一杯香槟，上面沾满了红唇膏。
She had a glass of water in a conference room scene that was like layered with red lipstick. I'm obsessed to that. I love that. If you need a quick adult beverage rundown, here it is, everybody. Oscar's going to join them. He's drinking what looks to be like an old-fashioned. Ned has a beer. And of course, we know Miss Martini and Esmeralda drinks champagne.
她在会议室的场景里喝过一杯水，上面全是一层层的红唇膏。我对此着迷。我太喜欢了。如果你需要一份简短的成人饮料总结，就是这样，各位。奥斯卡加入了他们。他喝的看起来像是老式鸡尾酒。内德喝的是啤酒。当然，我们知道马蒂尼小姐和埃斯梅拉达喝的是香槟。
What do you drink in real life? I love a martini. You do love a martini. Did they ask you what mayor wanted or what? Was that scripted? Yeah, yeah. I'm trying to remember of that moment. But, yeah, no, Taylor and I would always talk about that.
你在现实生活中喝什么？我喜欢马蒂尼。你确实喜欢马蒂尼。他们问过你梅尔想喝什么吗？还是那是剧本写的？对，对。我在努力回忆那个时刻。但是，是的，不，泰勒和我总是谈论这个。
I think she, a lot of wine, but, yeah, I figured, especially at the end of the night, feeling like maybe something is going to happen. Maybe she needs a little more liquid courage. The martini will get you. The martini will get you where you're going faster than most, you know? Are you two olives and your martini? I sure am. Extra dirty.
我想她，喝很多酒，但是，是的，我想象着，尤其是在深夜，觉得也许会发生点什么。也许她需要更多的液体勇气。马蒂尼会搞定一切的。马蒂尼会比大多数酒更快地带你到达你想去的地方，你知道吗？你的马蒂尼要加两颗橄榄吗？我当然要。超脏版（加多点苦艾酒/橄榄汁）。
Okay. This is drawing from real life. Yeah. Very good. Yeah. Yeah. I think it's, yeah, it's very ambitious to end a night with a martini, I think. But I think she knew. She had some plans. She had some plans. Yeah. That kind of get derailed. Yeah. So Ned leaves. Mare's totally put out that he bails in this moment. And then we see him get this speech from Oscar, which is basically Oscar is looking over at Marv, who's sitting alone by the fire drinking. And he's like, you know what? He's clearly in love with Anne. And why hasn't he done anything about it? And Ned's like, you know what? He's principled, right?
好的。这是取材于现实生活。非常好。是的。是的。我认为，是的，用一杯马蒂尼结束一天的夜晚是非常有野心的，我想。但我想她心里有数。她有她的计划。她有她的计划。是的。结果却泡汤了。是的。所以内德离开了。对于他在此时临阵脱逃，梅尔感到非常恼火。然后我们看到他从奥斯卡那里听了一席话，基本上是奥斯卡看着独自坐在壁炉旁喝酒的梅尔，然后他说，你知道吗？他显然爱着安。为什么他什么都不做呢？内德就说，你知道吗？他很有原则，对吧？他是她的老板。奥斯卡则反驳说，剥夺两个人的幸福一生算什么原则。然后奥斯卡引用了迈克尔·斯科特的话。好吧，他引用了一个伟人的话，他曾说过，你放弃了100%你没有尝试的投篮。然后他说，这也是我以前认识的一个白痴说的。他说的。太棒了。哦，我爱死那句台词了。
He's her boss. And Oscar's like denying two people a lifetime of happiness is principled. And then Oscar quotes Michael Scott. Well, he quotes a great man who once said you miss 100% of the shots you don't take. And then he says, also an idiot I used to know. He said that. That's great. Oh, I love that line.
但是，你知道，这开始深入他的内心了。内德离开了，我们看到他正走在酒店的走廊里。他走到一扇门前敲了敲。我们不知道那是谁的门。各位，那是梅尔的房间。她来开门。是的，所以他在你的门外，梅尔出来了，但她表现得很神秘，好像房间里有人，
But, you know, it's sinking in. Ned leaves, and we see that he's walking down a hotel hallway. He's going to go up to a door and knock. We don't know whose door it is. You guys, it's Mayer's room. She's going to answer the door. Yeah, so he's at your door, and Mayor comes out, but she's being secretive about, like, someone is in the room,
我们以为是西奥，但她还是溜了出来。她就说，什么？什么事？现在不是好时间。对，对。这就是他把演讲词交给你的时刻。他说，我想让你读读我本想说的话。这非常感人。
and we assume it's Theo, but she kind of slips out anyway. She's like, what? What is it? Not a good time. Yeah, yeah. And this is when he gives you the speech. And he says, like, I want you to read what I would have said. And it's very moving.
我们以为那是西奥，但她还是溜了出去。她问，什么？怎么了？现在不是好时机。对，对。这就是他给你演讲的时候。他说，我想让你读读我要说的话。这非常感人。
And he's like, okay, I know, forget it. I'll let you get back. I know you have someone in there, assuming it's Theo. But then you crack the door open and it reveals it's not Theo. It's Nicole. And this changes everything. It does. For Ned, for sure.
他说，好吧，我知道，算了吧。我让你回去。我知道里面有人，以为是西奥。但接着你推开门，发现那不是西奥。是妮可。这改变了一切。确实。对内德来说，绝对是。
Okay, let's listen. All right. This is probably awful to say, but that makes me really happy. If any of your reasons or any good, he would have laughed by now. You don't think I want to kiss you? I have no one. I want to kiss you. But this is our team.
好吧，我们听听。好的。这话听起来可能很糟糕，但这让我很高兴。如果你有任何好理由，他早就笑出来了。你以为我不想吻你吗？我谁也不想。我想吻你。但这是我们的团队。
You and me, we're just- Buddy and the dude. We're making it work. We're making the paperwork. This would be the classic fastest way to mess everything up. We can't do that. I don't know. Maybe we just need to like...
你和我，我们只是——拍档和伙计。我们在努力维持。我们在处理文件。这将是搞砸一切的最经典、最快的方式。我们不能那样做。我不知道。也许我们只是需要……
get it out of our system. Just get it out of the way so we can go back to being pals again. Well, I would love to be pals again. I know. I just feel like it's also going to suck now. It's been built up. But that would be great if it was terrible, because then we could go back to normal.
把这种情绪宣泄出来。彻底解决掉它，这样我们就能重新做回朋友了。哦，我很乐意再做朋友。我知道。我只是觉得现在感觉也会很糟。铺垫了这么久。不过如果这感觉很糟糕倒也不错，因为那样我们就能回到从前了。
Exactly. Because we would be a terrible idea. Yeah, I know. You've driving me crazy as it is. I just... Yeah. You know, we're journalists, and I feel like... We should verify. Should do the research.
没错。因为我们在一起会是个糟糕的主意。是的，我知道。你已经把我逼疯了。我只是……是的。你知道的，我们是记者，我觉得……我们应该核实一下。应该做点调研。
Okay, so approach. the palmaker. So first they do the little peck. Sure. Then there's the super steamy kiss. A lot of folks wrote in about it. Whoa. Wrote in about actually just this overall relationship in this moment.
好的，所以方法是。制造气氛。所以首先他们来个浅尝辄止的吻。当然。然后是超级火辣的吻。很多人写信来讨论这个。哇。写信来其实正是谈论这种整体关系和这个时刻。
Joanne B. from Philadelphia says, I wanted to give a shout out to the incredible performances of Donal and Chelsea for this episode. They have such great chemistry. There were several moments when Ned is looking at mayor at the table that were so sweet and heartbreaking all at once. And then we got this one from Samantha W. in Richmond, Virginia, who said throughout the season, Ned seemed to want to be the professional guy who wouldn't cross the line. I'm just wondering, when did the writers decide this was definitely going to be a storyline? Can you take us on this journey, this arc of the romance? When did you find out you guys were even going to kiss in this episode?
来自费城的乔安妮·B说，我想对多纳尔和切尔西在这集里不可思议的表演表示感谢。他们太有化学反应了。有好几次内德看着桌边的玛丽，那种眼神既甜蜜又让人心碎。然后我们收到了来自弗吉尼亚州里士满的萨曼莎·W的留言，她说整季下来，内德似乎一直想成为那个不会越界的专业人士。我只是想知道，编剧们是什么时候决定这绝对会是一条剧情线的？你能带我们回顾这段旅程，这段浪漫的情节弧线吗？你们是什么时候知道你们俩在这集里甚至要接吻的？
Was it at the table read or did you know before? Oh, that's a good question. Well, first of all, I'll say that from like minute one, it was something we talked about, like from shooting the pilot. It was kind of a push and pull of their both in love with the paper. Mare is so excited to finally have a job she cares about. Ned finally has his dream job. And there's this little bit of tension between the two of them. Right.
是在围读剧本的时候还是之前就知道？哦，这是个好问题。嗯，首先我要说，从第一分钟起，这就是我们一直在谈论的事情，比如从拍试播集开始。这就像是他们俩对报社都有一种拉扯感。玛丽终于找到了一份她真正关心的工作，感到非常兴奋。内德终于得到了他梦想的工作。他们两人之间存在着一点紧张感。没错。
So it was kind of something that constantly was talked about of like how far do we want to go with it? even like little looks between them in earlier episodes. It was like we don't want to give away too much. And also we don't totally know where it's going. And another thing we talked about a lot was the fact that it's only 10 episodes in the first season. And we didn't know if we're going to get another season or how many seasons we'll get. And what do we want to show? How far should they go in the first season?
所以这就像是一直在讨论的事情，比如我们想把这种关系推进到什么程度？甚至包括早期剧集中他们之间的小眼神。这就好像我们不想透露太多。而且我们也不是完全知道它会走向何方。我们讨论得很多的另一件事是，第一季只有10集。我们不知道是否还会有第二季，或者会有多少季。我们想展示什么？在第一季里他们应该发展到什么程度？
So when it came to the finale, I think episode nine really informed how far their relationship came again with like that road trip and then being together and spending all this time together and getting the news at the end of the nominations of the awards. I think it was all feeling like it was like, okay, something's got to happen by this point. Like somebody needs to at least try and acknowledge this. And the night before we shot the scene in the hallway, it was me, Donal, Paul Lieberstein, Jeffrey Blitz, Greg and Michael in a room in one of the hotel. hell rooms for like hours just talking about it and talking about our experiences with, you know, workplace relationships and how each of us felt. And we kind of came up with like a
所以当谈到大结局时，我认为第九集真正奠定了他们的关系进展到了什么地步，比如那次公路旅行，然后在一起，花所有这些时间相处，以及在最后听到提名奖项的消息。我觉得这一切都让人感觉，好吧，到了这个时候必须发生点什么了。比如总得有人至少尝试去承认这一点。就在我们在走廊拍那场戏的前一晚，我和多纳尔、保罗·利伯斯坦、杰弗里·布里茨、格雷格和迈克尔一起在其中一个酒店房间里待了几个小时，一直在讨论这件事，讨论我们对职场恋情的经历，以及我们每个人的感受。然后我们大概想出了……
million different ways it could end. And it was, well, let's just see, why don't we give some options. So when, you know, they finally put the whole season together, they can see if it feels right that they kiss or if it doesn't. But I think the idea was, just to clarify, I do think the table read scripted and have a kiss in it. But yeah, so we shot it a lot of different ways. But it's funny because, yeah, the version they ended up using, I think,
一百种不同的结局方式。那就是，好吧，让我们看看，为什么我们不提供一些选项呢。所以当他们最终把整季剪辑在一起时，他们就能看出接吻感觉对不对，或者是否不合适。但我认为这个想法是，澄清一下，我确实认为剧本围读时剧本里是有接吻的。但是是的，所以我们用很多不同的方式拍了这场戏。但很有趣，因为，是的，他们最终采用的版本，我觉得……
is always felt the most right. I'm glad we went for it. I think it was like something that was so scary and you're just so scared to like take the air and tension out of something like that. But I'm happy we went for it. It felt kind of like a swing. And it was like, you know what?
一直觉得是最对的。我很高兴我们尝试了。我觉得这就像是一件非常吓人的事情，你太害怕去抽离这种感觉和紧张感了。但我很高兴我们去做了。这感觉有点像是在冒险。就像是，你知道吗？
Yeah. Why not? I thought it was great. And it felt honest. you know, I loved that even in that moment, you see who they are to each other. Like, Mary's like, oh, come on. Really? You're just going to walk away now?
是的。为什么不呢？我觉得这很棒。这感觉很真实。你知道的，我喜欢即使在那一刻，你也能看出他们在彼此心中是谁。就像玛丽说的那样，哦，拜托。真的吗？你现在就要走开吗？
Yeah. You know? And then Ned, true to Ned, is like, come on in and kiss the pal maker. Like, I love that line. How much of that was scripted versus improvise? Oh, gosh. I think a lot of it was scripted, but we definitely, there were moments. I mean, one thing I loved that was scripted was that she.
是的。你知道吗？然后内德，不负内德之名，就像是来吧，进来吻一下制造气氛的人。我太喜欢这句台词了。这里面有多少是剧本写的，多少是即兴发挥的？哦，天哪。我觉得很大一部分是剧本写的，但我们确实也有一些即兴时刻。我的意思是，我喜欢的一个剧本设定是她……
She kind of uses the journalism elements to, like, just seduce him of, like, well, we should just, you know, I know how much you love verifying and researching. So, like, maybe if I word it this way, it'll seem like I can, I think she's, it's, I don't want to say manipulative, but I think there's. It's playful. It's sexy, too. Yeah. Right? It's like the role play. I think so.
她有点利用记者的元素来引诱他，比如，好吧，我们应该，你知道的，我知道你有多喜欢核实和调研。所以，也许我这样措辞，会显得我能……我觉得她，这，我不想说这是操纵，但我认为这其中有……这很俏皮。也很性感。是的。对吧？这就像角色扮演。我也这么觉得。
Yeah. Yeah. So, gosh, it's so, I'm trying to remember, like, what, there were definitely improvised moments. Like, I remember a few times when he'd, like, walk away. I'd be like, fuck off, dude. And we'd actually get, like, into a fight. And we tried so many different things. But it was one of those nights, the night before,
是的。是的。所以，天哪，太……我努力回想，有哪些……确实有即兴发挥的时刻。比如我记得有几次他要走开。我会说，滚开，老兄。我们甚至真的吵了起来。我们尝试了非常多不同的方法。但那是那些夜晚之一，就在前一天晚上，
Donald and I were just talking about it. We say, like, that was one of the most special nights ever getting to sit in a hotel room and just talk with the creators about, like, love and where we think this is going and what feels right. And it was just such a collaborative experience. And I just remember, like, finishing one of the takes. and Jeff Blitz coming out emotional. And he was, I love Jeff Flitz.
唐纳尔和我一直在谈论这个。我们说，那是史上最特别的夜晚之一，能坐在酒店房间里和创作者们聊爱情，聊我们认为这会走向何方，聊什么感觉才对。这真是一次极具合作精神的体验。我只记得，拍完其中一条之后，杰夫·布里茨情绪激动地走了出来。他说，我太爱杰夫·布里茨了。
Oh, we love Jeff Blitz. Is he not heaven on earth? He is. The best. Yeah, he's everything. Talk about a director that makes you feel really safe to take big chances. Yes.
哦，我们爱杰夫·布里茨。他难道不是人间天使吗？他是。最棒的。是的，他堪称完美。说起一个能让你在冒险时感到非常安全的导演，非他莫属。是的。
Yeah. And also giving us the space to be like, the cameras are going to be far away. We don't want you to even think that they're there because you can't think that they're there. Yeah, right. And that was also another really fun element of that scene because so much of the season, they are very aware that they're being filmed.
是的。而且还给我们空间，让我们觉得，摄像机会在很远的地方。我们甚至不需要去想它们的存在，因为你不能去想它们在那儿。是的，没错。这也是那场戏中另一个非常有趣的元素，因为在这一季的很大一部分时间里，他们都非常清楚自己正在被拍摄。
In that moment, they're not. But, yeah, I just remember Jeff coming out emotional. It made me so I was like, oh, gosh, I feel like, okay, maybe we did something remotely. Okay. You definitely did. And the final moment, I mean, there is a tag we'll get to, but the final moment of the actual episode is Ned being like, after the kiss, he goes, oh, shit. And then he may have this look to camera like, oh.
那一刻，他们没有。但是，是的，我只记得杰夫情绪激动地走出来。这让我觉得，哦，天哪，我觉得，好吧，也许我们做了一些还算不错的事。你绝对做到了。最后的时刻，我的意思是，还有一个彩蛋我们会讲到，但这一集实际内容的最后一个时刻是内德在接吻后说，哦，操。然后他对镜头露出了一个“哦”的表情。
Yeah, yeah, I think she's pretty pleased. But yeah, we talked about that, the different ways in which to end that scene. Some were him walking out, but I liked it ending with kind of like where could this possibly go. Well, it was great. I'm excited to see where it goes. Yeah, same. I can't wait for season two. Thank you.
对，对，我觉得她挺满意的。但是，是的，我们讨论过，结束那场戏的不同方式。有些是他走出去，但我喜欢以这样一种方式结束，那就是这一切究竟会走向何方。嗯，这很棒。我很期待看到它走向何方。是的，我也是。我等不及第二季了。谢谢。
Me too. And there's a delicious tag at the end of Esmeralda making a toast at the wedding that Ned and Maher got kicked out of. Yeah, it's hilarious. Definitely check that out. So good. This was so fun, Chelsea. I want to end with this one letter that we got. It's just some love from Laura and Veracruz, Mexico.
我也是。在内德和玛丽被赶出来的婚礼上，埃斯梅拉达发表了祝酒词，那里有一个非常美妙的彩蛋。是的，太搞笑了。一定要去看看。太棒了。这太有趣了切尔西。我想以我们收到的这封信来结束。这是来自墨西哥韦拉克鲁斯的劳拉的一份爱意。
She says, hello, ladies, this is not a question, but a theory I'd like to share. You know how little kids watch the same movie over and over again because it makes them feel safe? My theory is, the office is that movie, but for grownups, it's safe. We rewatch it a lot, and it makes us feel at home. So the paper felt just like that. A hug to all office fan's hearts from Greg. It has the same safe vibe as the office. And I think that scene where Ned and Mare finally kiss is Greg putting everything right into place again for us.
她说，嗨，女士们，这不是一个问题，而是一个我想分享的理论。你知道小孩子们是如何一遍又一遍地看同一部电影的，因为这让他们感到安全吗？我的理论是，《办公室》就是那部电影，但对于成年人来说，它是安全的。我们反复观看它，它让我们有家的感觉。所以《报社》给人的感觉正是如此。格雷格献给所有《办公室》粉丝内心的拥抱。它有着和《办公室》一样安全的氛围。我想内德和玛丽终于接吻的那场戏，就是格雷格为我们把一切又重新安排妥当。
I never feared for something to go terribly wrong with the characters because I know Greg's got our backs. Love you. Bye. Mara. Oh, my gosh. That's so sweet. Thank you. Okay, that just made me emotional.
我从不担心这些角色会发生什么糟糕的错误，因为我知道格雷格会支持我们。爱你们。再见。玛丽。哦，天哪。太甜了。谢谢。好吧，这直接让我感动了。
That was very sweet. Yeah, it's like an honor to be just even in the same world and presence. I can't believe I even get to sit across from you guys right now. It's truly insane when I think about it as somebody who used to watch the show when I was growing up. So it makes me really happy that it made you feel that way, Laura. Thank you. Well, you have big fans, two of them sitting right here with you in this room. And we are super excited for season two.
那非常甜。是的，能甚至在这个世界和氛围中出现，简直是一种荣幸。我简直不敢相信我现在能和你们坐在对面。当我作为一个从小看着这部剧长大的人回想起来时，这真是太疯狂了。所以这让我非常高兴它让你有了这种感觉，劳拉。谢谢。嗯，你有很多粉丝，其中两个就坐在房间里陪着你。我们对第二季超级兴奋。
Thank you. Me too. And we'll hopefully get to chat more. Thank you for answering all of our texts. as we've broken down the paper. And thank you for coming in today on a Sunday on your day off to talk about the finale. No place I'd rather be. Thank you guys so much for having me.
谢谢。我也是。希望我们能聊更多。谢谢你们回答我们的所有短信，当我们在剖析这部剧时。也谢谢你们今天周日休息天还抽空来聊大结局。再也没有比这更好的地方了。非常感谢你们邀请我。
Yay, Chelsea. So breaking down the paper. We did it. We did it. Season one. Done. Lady, how great was it that we got to do the finale with Chelsea Fry? She is such a gem.
耶，切尔西。所以在剖析这部剧。我们做到了。我们做到了。第一季。完成了。女士们，能和切尔西·弗莱一起做大结局节目太棒了。她真是一块瑰宝。
She really is. I mean, not only for her amazing performance on the show and coming on our episode and answering all of our texts throughout the season, but she's just a lovely person through and through, and I can't wait to see what they do for season two. Well, everyone, thanks for watching along with us. We have some really cool episodes coming up that we think you're going to love. Yes, we are diving back into the world of the office. We have some very fun, all about episodes with your favorite characters and some very exciting interviews coming out, and also just chit-chatting. So please keep sending us in your chit-chats, you around the towns and office questions of the week.
她真的是。我的意思是，不仅因为她在剧中的精彩表演，还因为她来参加我们的节目并回答了我们整季的短信，而且她自始至终都是一个可爱的人，我等不及看他们为第二季准备了什么。好了，各位，谢谢你们和我们一起收看。我们接下来有一些非常酷的节目，相信你们一定会喜欢的。是的，我们要重新潜入《办公室》的世界。我们将与你最喜欢的角色进行一些非常有趣的全方位访谈，还会有一些非常令人兴奋的采访推出，当然也有闲聊。所以请继续给我们发送你们的闲聊、身边趣事和每周办公室问题。
We love hearing from you. So we'll see you back next week. We're going to be sharing some office news and also talking about the office webisode blackmail. You guys, it is really creeds time to shine. It's all about his character. And you're going to love it. So we'll see you next week.
我们喜欢听你们分享。所以我们下周见。我们将分享一些《办公室》的新闻，还会讨论《办公室》的网络剧《勒索》。各位，这真的是克里德的高光时刻。全都是关于他的角色的。你们一定会喜欢的。所以我们下周见。
See you then. Thank you for listening to Office Ladies. Office Ladies is a presentation of Odyssey and is produced by Jenna Fisher and Angela Kinsey. Our senior producer is Matt Beagle. Our audio engineer is Sam Kiefer, and our associate producer is Ainsley Bubbicoe. Odyssey's executive producer is Leah Reese Dennis. Office Ladies was mixed and mastered by Bill Schultz. Our theme song is Ruppertry by Creed Bratton. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
到时候见。感谢收听“办公室女士们”。“办公室女士们”是奥德赛（Audyssey）的一档节目，由珍娜·费舍尔和安吉拉·金西制作。我们的资深制作人是马特·比格尔。我们的音频工程师是萨姆·基弗，我们的副制作人是艾斯利·布比科。奥德赛的执行制作人是莉亚·里斯·丹尼斯。本期节目由比尔·舒尔茨进行混音和母带制作。我们的主题曲是克里德·布拉顿创作的《鲁珀特里》。这集节目还没有评论。点击剧本中的任意句子即可留下评论。